e
I call this hearing to order we'll start
off with the pledge pledge of allegiance
us aliance to the flag
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all Mr clerk can you call roll
here proud sorry
Warden here
Drago Drago here
Granger here Fairington here
Hall kessle ring here leine here
Sullivan here kahill here Del Sylvester
here okay Susi here rard here McKenzie
he's he's
here somewhere Schultz present lir here
stab
here I hereby open the hearing on House
Bill 238 FN an act prohibiting
collective bargaining agreements from
requiring employees to join or
union we're really excited to hear what
everyone has to say today you know we've
been looking forward to this hearing for
a long time and and uh I think it's
going to be a great
day uh we have well over 30 cards here
and
so uh we're really interested in what
everyone has to
say um but we need to be respectful of
each other's time otherwise we'll be
here until next year and we have one day
set for this
hearing
um when you're testifying please try not
to repeat what you've heard many times
before okay and if you have new
testimony that's awesome
so I always go by the saying be
brilliant be brief and be gone and uh if
you if you think in those terms and get
your point across that would be
great
um we're going to allow the the the bill
to be opened and for the prime sponsor
to have more than three minutes uh but
everyone else we're going to limit to
three minutes so if you could please
figure out what you got to say
and uh and get it done we are going to
have uh timer the vice chair
representative avalani will will be the
timer and when he says it's 3 minutes
that's 3 minutes okay so please don't
argue just find yourself another
seat
um outside of that I think we're ready
quorum and rep
sir so we had a discussion relative to
the timing of this yesterday and it was
not my impression yesterday that we were
going to limit testimony yeah in the
discussion yes fair enough in the
discussion yesterday we said we were
going to look at the number of
cards and and looking at the number of
cards uh if you do 3 minutes times 30 um
that's a ton of testimony and that's
only just to start off with so to be
fair to every one we're going to start
by limiting it to 3 minutes and
representative Solomon and I have agreed
to that um as a as a way forward we talk
point okay uh representative glasson uh
are you here to introduce HB
238 Mr chair yes sir I am okay the floor
is yours
sir uh Mr chair thank you honorable
representatives of the committee it is
my uh distinct honor to represent uh to
introduce House Bill 238 which would end
forced union membership as a condition
of employment again what this bill does
is it gives Freedom of Choice as to
whether or not joining a union is
correct for
you and that can't be held against you
as a condition of your
employment in states that have done this
before we found that unions better
represent their membership in their
employees when their employees have the
influence of being able to walk away
being able to withdraw their
contributions and you know when your
membership has the power to say you're
not well representing me and find other
representation or self- represent
without continuing to pay dues the
unions have paid more attention to their
labor force and better represented
them um there are also clear cases and
I'll be followed in testimony which will
um be able to better tell you about the
states that have enacted this have seen
a decrease in unemployment and an
increase in business coming into the
state which especially in this state
where we have the tax problem that we
have with personal property tax would
bring other sources of revenue and
employment into the state um again if
this passes membership will have more
influence on their unions this doesn't
affect people who are happy with their
Union representation this does not stop
unions from doing the best that they can
for their employ uh for their membership
if you like your you should continue to
participate in your union what this does
is this makes unions an option you know
I want people to join unions because
they find Value in what the union is
doing for them and they recognize and
support the benefits that they're
getting out of that membership not
because they're forc to as a condition
of their
payroll so this is the bill that I'm
introducing and proud to introduce um I
won't be taking questions because I'll
be followed by a lot of subject matter
experts thank you for your
yeah there okay what what I'm going to
do is I'm going to call the next two the
first one is it will take the stand and
then next one's on deck in case we have
two overflow rooms and so if they're in
the Overflow room they can make their
way
forward um Riot
Gul gulla RI Gula
good morning my name is I is your is
your mic on there y good morning um
honorable chairman um distinguished
Representatives my name is Richard gulla
I am president of the state employees
Association of New Hampshire represent
approximately 15,000 employees in the
state County Municipal and private
sectors uh I will be brilliant and brief
how's that I want to uh take a moment to
highlight an article that uh was printed
last month that I penned in that was
printed in the New Hampshire Journal I'm
not going to read this entire article I
would ask you to do that but I am going
to read an excerpt from the
article want to take a moment to address
the arguments made by those promoting
so-called right to work laws and the
claim that such legislation would
benefit New Hampshire the evidence tells
a very different story among the 27
states where right to work laws are in
effect wages and standards of living are
constantly lower compared to states
without these laws take West Virginia
for example when right to work was
enacted there it failed to attract new
business or spur economic growth even
West Virginia governor Jim Justice
acknowledged the reality in Stark terms
quote really and truly let's just be
brutally honest Governor Justice said
during a town hall meeting we passed the
right to work law West Virginia we ran
to the windows looked to see all the
people that were going to come and guess
what they didn't come we got rid of
prevailing wage we changed our corporate
tax taxes we've done a lot of different
things and we run to the windows and
they haven't come we've absolutely built
the field in a lot of different places
thinking building the field they'll come
and they didn't come right to Work
legislation has been sponsored in this
state for well over 30 to 35 times this
is my 11th time at bat as head of this
organization testifying against it for
the life of me what I can't understand
is why um Republican party which
preaches Less business Le uh less
interference with business less
government wants to interfere with
agreements between a business and their
employees no one is forced to join a
union that fair share clause which was
referenced by the the sponsor of this
bill has to be negotiated between the
business and the employees and I think
we should stay out of the business of
Private Business government has no
business in that and um with that thank
you thank you sir are there any
questions represent McKenzie thank you
uh president Gull uh the the discussion
about whether or not somebody's forced
to join a union can you just give us a
sense of of that how that works in the
SEIU um no one's forced to join um we go
to an orientation we talk about um the
benefits of joining a Union and if
someone wants to join then they're
eligible to join if they don't they
don't it's literally how it works thank
you okay thank you so much thank you for
your time Greg Moore and on Deck will be
Keith
judge good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Greg Moore I'm a regional director
with Americans for Prosperity and I'm
here today test in support of House Bill
238 um I'll tell a few quick stories
that I have while I have the through the
three minutes the first one is why this
issue is personal to me I was working at
DHHS as a director in 2005 and 2006 when
the state enacted an agency fee and I
had one of my employees come in tears
about the fact that money was being
withheld from her paycheck despite the
fact that she didn't agree with the
direction the union was bargaining on
her behalf um fundamentally I think that
that's why a lot of PE a lot of
non-members in Union environments don't
join is because they don't feel as
though the Union's best negotiating in
their interest and I would say and I
would say that that uh that's a lot of
the reason it's I I liken it to this
it's like going to a restaurant or
ordering a chicken Caesar salad getting
a cheeseburger told you have to pay for
the cheeseburger and if you complain
about it you're called ungrateful Second
Story uh with one of our activists
worked in Massachusetts in a union shop
he was part of a a smaller younger group
of people who were on a 401K plan there
was an older larger group more senior
folks who were on a Divine benefit plan
for them uh they uh they had a
negotiation and the negotiating team
which is largely made up of older
members got more money into the defined
benefit plan and the younger workers got
nothing now in a right to work state
that wouldn't happen because those those
uh members would immediately leave
because they would it would be obvious
that they're not negotiating on their
behalf third quick story when I was
working as uh I before with I was AFP
was a chief of staff of the house and in
2011 we passed right to work in the
house passed right to work in the Senate
and then it was an interim period
because the governor vetoed it waiting
for the veto day we used to have
business owners actually show up across
the street come up and talk to the
speaker and tell us that they would that
if we passed right to work they would
move to the state now I was curious I
didn't know why and I wanted to know why
they would do that and because you hear
the argument that there's less pay
that's not had nothing to do with it at
all the reason why they want to come to
a right to work state is because there's
more labor peace people in in the union
are happier and that helps to in
incentivize Recruitment and Retention
and particularly in the manufacturing
space getting and keeping good people is
really critical so for all these reasons
and I could go on for more but I get
three minutes so I'll stop there and be
happy to take any
questions thank you sir any questions
representative
Schultz thank you Mr chair good to see
you Mr Moore um I'm curious to know
because I know Americans for Prosperity
um has spoken on this in the past I'm
curious to know if if you or your
organization supports the right for
unions to exist at all absolutely thank
you for the question uh we believe that
people if they want to get together and
engage in Collective action that's fine
uh the real challenge that we have uh
comes from the Wagner Act which states
back to 1935 that says that if 50% plus
one member of a bargaining unit decide
to join a union the minority lose all
their rights they lose their right to
negot neate they lose the right to
represent themselves they lose all their
rights and have to go exclusively
through the union so fundamentally the
the challenge we have is is with
exclusive representation not not unions
themselves but thank you for the
question I'm glad to
clarify representative K thank you Mr
chair and uh thank you Mr Moore uh what
you just described is sounds like
democracy are you opposed to democracy
I'm I'm could you please explain yeah
well you said said the members decide
they vote at 50% plus one uh wants to
have a union then they have a union and
the other people you feel aren't
represented but I think in fact that
negotiations and benefits and everything
negotiated by the union apply to
everyone who does work in that in that
company so it seems to me they are
getting a benefit you're just you just
reluctant to pay the agency fee to help
cover the cost but to my point 50 % plus
one in a vote that's how democracy Works
correct and and thankfully we don't have
a democracy in the US we have a
constitutional republic where our rights
constitution my goodness I I thought we
did have democracy in where we we vote
and the majority wins I'm sorry Gman
this is not a an argument back and forth
questions and answers please any other
questions representa
Soloman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question um you mentioned that um
businesses have been talking about uh
wanting to come to uh New Hampshire if
we pass right to work could you name a
few of those businesses that are anxious
to come to New Hampshire under those
circumstances and that's and that's the
game right there uh the The Business
Leaders would come up they would say if
you pass right to work we'll pass it
however until you pass right to work you
cannot mention that we said
that and there's a reason for that
because because undoubtedly there would
be trouble caused back within the other
New England States in which they're
located and they said and they made
abundantly clear that they that they are
not willing to put their name to
anything for that
reason are there any other
questions all right oh I'm sorry
representative McKenzie thank you thank
you Mr
Moore uh you uh suggested that organized
labor um promotes
unrest you talked about Labor
Peace So are are you suggesting that
organized labor um uh promotes unrest
and undermines uh the economic
conditions in New Hampshire undermines
the economic the economy generally
speaking in New Hampshire so when I
mentioned labor piece what I meant was
when the union is representing the
entirety of the workforce the entirety
of the bargaining unit that is a more
harmonious workplace if you have a
scenario where you can have a majority
of the people decide that they want some
want something and they get it and the
minority of the people did not want it
and they're left out and excluded then
that that's obviously going to leave
them less happy and less likely to stay
and less likely to encourage their
workplace
sir repr LK thank you Mr chair so
wouldn't this legislation kind of mess
with the harmony of unions by saying
okay if you want to be a member but
don't want to pay dues or you know help
um help keep the union strong isn't that
saying you know you can pay you don't
have to pay if you don't want to but
doesn't that create
unrest I don't know how it creates
unrest when the union is more focused on
making sure all their members are happy
I think that would create um a more
positive
workplace yeah thank you Mr
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question if you do not want to be a
member of the union and you're in a
union shop how are you are you able to
independently negotiate your own wages
and just say I'm going to do it on my
own under federal law no if you have a a
a bargaining unit that has been
certified by the National Labor
Relations Board you lose your ability to
go and negotiate for your own uh
compensation benefits time off anything
like that it is exclusively done by on
on behalf of of the Union
thank
you representative McKenzie uh can you
uh uh provide uh just heard the term
Union
shop so what is a union shop so a union
shop is is well it depends if you have a
certified Union shop one is certified by
the National Labor Relations Board it is
a shop that wherein there has been a a a
union organizing effort where where one
Union has gotten certified by 50% plus
one that's not the only type of Union
shop there are member only unions there
are actually some workplaces that have
multiple member only unions that
represent their people and the people
who are not member of of the member on
unions negotiate on their own
behalf but there are no there are no clo
shops under Taft heartley there are no
close shops I think I think that's what
you're getting at that's what I'm
getting okay I want so we got there
followup for a followup so close shop
would mean that you could not work in
that
in that facility if you didn't join the
union correct between 1935 and 1947
there were closed shops
where full union membership was a
condition of employment right no longer
the case that's that V outlawed by Taff
Harley in 1947 the same legislation that
created the right to work
exception so people can join don't have
to join the union they can work in a
shop that's a union shop and don't have
to join the union is that you have
testimony that's correct that's federal
law thank you repr Granger thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
if you if you have these protections
that you mentioned that means that you
don't have to pay union dues or pay to
the union anything correct if you're not
a member of the union or no correct if
if uh if New Hampshire were to become
the 27th right to work
state uh if you are not a member you
would not have to pay any fees or dues
to the union thank you very much
representative
brard thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question with studies
indicating that right to work states
often have higher rates of
workplace injuries how can you ensure me
that weakening unions won't lead to less
enforcement of safety regulations in New
Hampshire I think that's a great
question there have been some studies
looking specifically at that uh one of
the challenges is that the states are
right to work states are often more
Agricultural and agricultural uh
environments actually lead to higher
workplace accidents so that's one
important factor to keep in mind but uh
there have been a number of studies I
saw one by the MAA Institute that uh
basically undermined the notion that
that um it's less safe to work in a
state with Right to Work protections I
wish I had that study with
me I
laby thank you Mr chair uh good to see
you Mr Moore question for you regarding
the North Country um the North Country
could use industry it doesn't have much
and it could use a hand how would this
law help or hurt the North Country well
I would think the the North country and
thank you for the question um as my
representative thank you uh I would I
would assume that that the place that
businesses coming to New Hampshire would
First Look would be the North country
and that's because a there's space
available and B there's more workers
available it is hard as as you know as a
business owner it's hard to find people
these days in Southern New Hampshire uh
so I would think that the North Country
would be uniquely positioned to benefit
from the passage of a right to work
law repres
McKenzie
uh are you familiar with the history of
the North country in terms of the union
movement I uh representative I am
familiar uh as it turns out when I was
working at DHHS was when they were
closing many of the mills in Lancaster
and uh in in Berlin so so the that was a
union town there were thousands of union
Berlin okay any further
questions represent brard thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh given that right to work
laws correlate with fewer
employer um sponsor benefits
how can you ensure me that New
Hampshire's workers won't see a decline
in health coverage and retirement
options what defines benefits and and
what defines compensation is is usually
Marketplace forces uh at today and in an
environment where you can talk to any
small business owner or anyone who's
hiring anybody uh you can't for example
hire people in in the greater Manchester
area for any less than about $20 an hour
you just can't and so fundamentally what
tends to drive compensation and benefit
are are
essentially Market forces competing for
labor particularly when you have Labor
scarcity unemployment in New Hampshire
is 2% and the greatest challenge that we
would have uh for employers looking to
come to New Hampshire or finding a
Workforce and you can and doesn't take
much you can talk to any any employer
around they'll tell you that the biggest
problem they have is finding and keeping
okay uh representative K thank you Mr
chair Mr MOA do you really think that
rights to work is the biggest concern
that employers have when looking at a
state uh don't you think that uh
Workforce housing and educated Workforce
uh School functions uh schools that are
functioning well and and well financed
and maintained don't you think those are
other considerations for both businesses
and workers I can tell you that there
are many considerations every single
employer on making decision for sighting
it looks at a number of different
factors for example up until about 10
years ago we had some of the highest uh
business taxes in in in the country we
were 40 ranked 47th uh thankfully over
the course of the last 10 years we have
made our business tax environment much
more competitive and that spurred a
significant number of amount of economic
growth so to your point yes there are a
number of factors that businesses
consider when they decide to relocate
right to work is simply one of them
thank
you I seeing no further questions I'll
call the next witness thank
you uh Keith judge please and
Deck please state your name and and who
you
represent and can you turn your mic on
please has to be red hear me now perfect
uh good morning thank you for convening
this hearing my name is Keith judge and
I am a business agent for teams's local
633 and I am a resident of hookit I'm
also a town counselor of the town of
hookit uh and I come to testify an
opposition of this bill uh prior to my
career as a business agent because the
last thing I think you guys want to hear
is some testimony of the quote unquote
Union boss I was a rank and file member
of teamer local 633 at Associated
groceries where I operated at forklift
uh I could sit here and tell you the
talking points of anti-right to work
being it drives down wages it drives
down benefits but that's not what I'm
here to tell you uh if it were not for
my union and the and the benefits
negotiated uh by local 633 when I was a
ranked file member I physically would
not be here to make this testimony today
as a rank and file member at Associated
groceries I was diagnosed with stage 4 a
scream aell carcinoma tonsil
cancer during those treatments my union
negotiat health insurance saved my life
on more than one occasion the nurses the
doctors all went to my wife and said
your your husband is getting the best uh
care due to his health insurance I was
never once asked to leave the facility
to free up a bed which I know happens uh
when you have health insurances that
don't do what they're supposed to do
that never happened once I was cleared
and go back to work uh my FMLA uh
protections had run out uh my union was
able to keep my job my position I was
able to go back to work all right
without the negotiated benefits uh by
unions uh the American worker especially
workers in New Hampshire will be
completely unprotected make no mistake
about it Right to Work legislation is
strictly a way to weaken unions and take
away negotiating power from the people
that are trying to negotiate and take
uh let me see
oh yeah so again with the uh terms and
conditions which I worked under I had
short-term disability coverage uh when I
was out and that was the only money
coming in when I was out not being able
to work to provide groceries for my
family you overall being a part of a
union uh has been the best decision uh
right to work laws are just bad for the
American worker bad for New Hampshire we
have fought this fight for the last 30
plus years and it always gets shot down
right uh in my opinion and and my
professional life as a business agent
I've heard I've heard some testimony
already about work shortages and and
needing employers excuse me needing uh
workers uh in my experience there's not
really a worker shortage those employers
who provide the best wages benefits and
retirement are not looking for employees
because they say fully staffed you know
that's the purpose of of unions uh here
to protect the workers create create
safe working environments good wages and
uh under retirement and great health
insurance so uh I could again tell you
how Right to Work lowers wages benefits
safety but I don't want to I only got
three minutes so I will make that my
testimony answer any questions that you
have thank you sir appreciate that
representative Schultz thank you Mr
chair um Mr judge I'm so glad that your
health uh and everything I'm sure that
everybody feels this way I'm so glad it
worked out for you um I'm sad that uh
some folks don't have that coverage and
as I will as a point of personal
privilege I'm a granddaughter and
daughter of a teamers so I really
appreciate you being here thank
um why do you think under President
Trump the GOP has removed the right to
work um plank from the national
Republican platform and I am aware that
your union internationally did not take
a stand on the presidential election as
a Democrat I was smid and sad about that
but I think in this sense uh this this
question is is a good one to ask you as
a Teamster can you ref uh repeat the
question yes why why do you think that
under President Trump the GOP took the
plank supporting right to work um out of
the national platform for the for the
Republican Party under President
Trump's um leadership uh I can only give
you my opinion I know that recently the
Republican party has attempted to become
the uh party of the working people uh
that may have been a step in the right
direction uh you know but I believe it's
no disrespect it's a bit of sod because
one of the first uh bills here in New
Hampshire right out of the gate with a
republican uh Governor is is Right to
Work uh I do believe there are great
Republicans especially here in New
Hampshire who have sided with us uh but
I do believe inherently it's still part
of their National platform even if
they're not out in
front are there any further questions
one quick one every ler thank you uh
thank you Mr judge for your testimony my
dad was a teamer to and he was very sick
for a long time and his benefits kept
him alive until uh he finally
succumbed to uh with cancer but my
question is are you forced to pay dues
or you do it voluntarily say that again
are you forced to pay dues or do you do
it voluntarily no um in all of
our in all of our public sector
contracts you can you can op out from
paying dues uh but in our private sector
contracts uh those that have uh those
Provisions in the contract are voted on
uh by all the members at Contract
renewal and there's also the um
objective fee so you're not forced to
pay dues if you don't if you so choose
not
to every
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman I too
Paid Dues to the teamsters when I was in
college I didn't get any benefits other
than maybe a better pay and allow me to
work it but I am also glad that you're
doing well thanks sir um there was
something that was brought up um oh when
you say you're voluntarily paying uh
your dues you didn't bring up agency is
agency viewed as different than
dues the uh obor fee is that agency fee
agency fee public sector that's the now
know the Janice decision right but do
you
have with the private I
understand is there an opport
where even in the private sector that an
individual an employee can just pay the
agency fee the cost of negotiating like
yes you call it something different than
yeah it's the same thing uh what was not
brought up and what I'd like to mention
under that uh if Right to Work were to
pass uh Unions would be obligated to
represent those employees who are not
paying dues or an objective fee at all
and I would believe uh I stand to be
corrected that unions are the only
organization in this country that would
be forced to provide
uh services to people without paying for
them uh I is a not a member of AAA could
not call triaa and say hey I'm broke
down on the side of the road come change
my tire the first thing they're going to
do is say are you uh a are you a member
and B are you dues paid up and if
they're not they're not comeing to
change your tire so I think it's
inherently wrong that under right to
work laws Unions would be forced to
represent uh people who aren't paying
share uh for a quick followup so
basically your answer is yeah you can
either pay dues or you call it something
different than agency fee right you have
a the objective fee thank you very much
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so you mentioned that um you
guys are the unions are forced to
represent people who are not members of
the unions are there unions that do not
represent
illegal for a quick followup what about
the members only
unions I'm not unaware of anyone in New
Hampshire thank you for taking my
question seeing no questions thank you
sir for your testimony thanks sir and
I'm glad you
recovered and representative Opel is up
Deck really quickly from the committee's
perspective remember we're about an
asking questions and it's it's not a
political form for statements and those
types of things thank you very
much Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh thank you for the
opportunity my name is Thomas Opel and I
represent the people of Kanan Dorchester
and orange in Grafton house District 9
UM and Mr chairman I promise to be brief
I'm not sure about the brilliant
part um I'm appearing before you today
to strongly oppose uh House Bill 23 8 FN
um as others have or will note with all
of the cards um this bill is nothing
more than attempt to deceive and confuse
it has nothing to do with real rights it
has nothing to do with real work and it
won't create real work it simply permits
a few to Advantage themselves at the
expense of others and those few will
endure no cost no
sacrifice um uh at in in a in a right to
work
situation this bill actually undermines
the competitive balance that workers
seek to achieve in a free market through
Collective
action it is anti-competitive to allow
some to take advantage of that
Collective action without participating
in it or supporting
it we've seen the debilitating impacts
of socalled Right to Work legislation on
workers in many other states the data
from the e Economic Policy Institute
shows full-time workers in states that
have adopted this falsely named and
deceptively intended
legislation can earn nearly $1,700 less
per year with no no measurable gains in
employment the race to the Bottom by
states to attract companies by offering
lower wages than their neighbors can be
seen simply by driving along the banks
of the marac and Manchester
those Mills now do employ people but if
you were here in New Hampshire 30 or 40
or 50 years ago those Mills were
empty all of that work taken by Amis and
other manufactures to the
South for lower pay that was all it was
about and having lived in Mississippi
for 10 years I can tell you that all of
those companies that mov to the South
have now moved to Mexico or southeast
Asia again in that race to the
bottom in the 1950s more than a third of
us workers were unionized and our
economy grew to become the Envy of the
world with GDP growth averaging more
than
4% today only one in 10 workers are
unionized and GDP growth is less than
half of what it was when unions were
strong the evidence is clear unions not
only do not cost jobs or limit rights
they support living wages Fair working
conditions if youve just heard and they
actually create an educated and safe
Workforce that is the attraction for
most all right sir your time is up thank
you thank you so much any
questions Schultz Mr chair I just wanted
to point out that he has a typed version
of his speech and as a former Clerk of
this committee I think it's helpful for
us to have copies of that in the in the
main folder for the record absolutely
thank you I did bring copies so okay if
we can hand those around that would be
perfect thank you for your testimony
thank
you I'd like to call John Reynolds
please and on Deck
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today thank you sorry I hope
I didn't jump the gun uh my name is John
Reynolds I'm the state director for the
national Federation of Independent
Business in New Hampshire we represent
over 1700 small businesses in every
sector in every corner of the State uh
our mission is to promote and protect
the right of our members to own operate
and grow their
business excuse me
uh fundamentally our members believe
that right to work work is about
allowing small business owners and their
employees to determine their own future
uh in nfib surveys of New Hampshire
small businesses over 80% support right
to work and notably in other states when
the question has come up about retaining
the policy support is even higher closer
to 90% uh also academic research backs
the benefits of right to work and there
are a number of studies some of which
I've cited in the letter that was
distributed uh I think one of the most
notable ones is a 2021 study by
researchers at University which examined
the long-range impacts of right to work
in Border counties and states that with
and without the policy and the study
looked at not only counties immediately
adjacent to the Border but one County in
on each side as well so effectively it
would apply to the entire city New
Hampshire and what they found in
addition to evidence uh to suggest
higher average wages the researchers at
Harvard also concluded that right to
work is associated with higher
population growth higher employment to
population higher share of manuf
facturing employment higher rates of
upward economic Mobility lower rates of
unemployment and lower rates of poverty
so in some we want continued economic
growth in the state of New Hampshire we
want New Hampshire to be an even more
attractive place for people to live work
raise a family start a business and
that's why we believe that right to work
is the right policy at the right time
thank you
again thank you sir I appreciate that
representative Susi thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so I'm sure that every
representative in here received the same
letter um from the citizens or right to
work
movement and for years I've been here
this is my eth term so I've been dealing
with this for 14 years and that letter
that we received said that 80% of New
Hampshire citizens believe that they
should have the right to work do you
have data to back that up because it
hasn't changed the number hasn't changed
in all the letters that I've received
over 14 years Mr chair representative
Susi uh nfib is not affiliated or
associated with the I'm sorry which
organization did you say for Right to
Work movement because you had mentioned
you that right to work people in New
Hampshire 80% of the people in New
Hampshire believe that it's right to
work is the right thing to do and I'm
asking if you have any data to back that
up yes uh so the number I cited which is
the act the specific number I think is
about 82% support 5 or 6% oppose 11% or
so have no opinion that comes from an
nfib member survey of small businesses
I'm not aware of any other broad-based
poll or survey of small businesses in
the state on this question so I and
again we're just speaking for ourselves
and our
members I was ask
solivan thank you for Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh you
referenced a Harvard study
um can you um tell us exactly who the
author of that study was and uh what
their background is um I can I certainly
can share a copy of the study with all
the members of the committee I know the
last names of the researchers were
Austin and Lily the title is the long
run long run effects of right to work
laws it was published on November 16th
of 2021 I'd be happy to follow up with
you over email with a copy of the study
thank you
followup yes
sir are you aware that that study was
not
peer-reviewed uh I looked um was not
aware it was peer-reviewed I looked for
any other uh studies that refuted the
findings and I didn't find
any thank you and
ma'am okay thank you so much I was
exactly uh thank you and thank you for
taking the question would you just uh
explain to me what a small business is
how many people and it's like an ex
essal question uh so there's a lot of
different um thresholds for small
businesses I'll just say 80 I forget if
I said this at the outset so I apologize
if I'm repeating myself but for us our
80% of our members employ 20 people or
fewer so you know we tend to be on the
very small side uh if you look at the
United States ball Business Association
uh the federal SBA um they're General
across the board threshold right for
between large and small as 500 employees
um and then when you get into industry
specific Thresh it ranges between you
know 100 less than 100 could be a small
business in some cases or less than 1500
could be a small business in some cases
if you look at different Federal Acts
like the federal Family Medical and
Leave Act 50 and or I'm sorry under 50
employees are exempt from that
regulation so you could argue right
that's a threshold same thing for the
Affordable Care Act Right the employer
mandate to provide coverages applies to
50 and
above thank you representative farington
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question I believe that West
Virginia is the closest state with Right
to Work legislation given that what
effect would having passing this have on
New Hampshire small businesses yeah um
I'll again point back to the Harvard
study which is also supported by earlier
research I think and here I think I
cited a paper from the Federal Reserve
Bank of Richmond uh right and the
findings in both instances and other
academic research right so strongly
suggests higher employment higher rates
of employment lower poverty um higher
rates of employment in sectors that uh
are known for having good pay good
benefits like manufacturing um so I
think the the benefits right we we would
be a leader in in New England uh by
law representative kahill thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh in New Hampshire really the
the vast majority of employers in the
state are small businesses and we
appreciate
and uh you know their concerned and
uh 84% have fewer than 15 employees do
you have any idea how many currently are
have unions in those businesses and is
businesses was a timed out on me I think
um sorry representative I'm just
replaying your question in my head uh do
I have data on could you repeat the
question apologize well there are 84% of
the com of the businesses in New
Hampshire the small businesses where our
small business they have 15 employees or
fewer are could you have any an idea of
how many of those have unions in those
businesses to that part of the question
I I don't have the rate of unionization
in that size business off the top of my
head but I'd certainly be happy to track
it down and follow up with you after the
committee to your second question about
the level of I believe it was about the
level of concern uh yes if I if I may
yes sir thank you well I I believe that
there are probably very few it's my
belief that there are probably very few
unions operating in such small
businesses and we have so many small
businesses in New Hampshire I just
wonder if that's this issue is a real
pressing concern for our small
businesses in New
Hampshire uh I I can you know speak from
talking to small business owner I can
speak from just personal experience
without having data in front of me I
know that you know there are certainly
Union shops um with fewer than 15 20 25
whatever number you want to pick to
Define small employer right there there
certainly what number that is I I will
follow up after committee uh as to the
level of concern I could speak to our
membership right um and the way that
nfib works is that we every year survey
our members on a range of questions a
range of policy issues we ask them you
know do you support or oppose this
policy and over 80% supported right to
work so I glean from that that this is
an issue of concern for a lot of our
members thank you m Jan Flanigan thank
you Mr chair and just as a point of
clarification unless it has changed I
thought uh you had to have at least 10
employees to unionize in the state of
New Hampshire
that was public employers
okay okay thank you so much sir thank
you and we have um Lisa bodden
Bodine and on Deck
please
Hena
Tran thank you the floor is yours ma'am
good morning my name is Lisa Bodwin for
for the record I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Council of
churches and on behalf of the council I
wish to express our strong opposition to
HB
238 as a faith-based organization
representing Seven Christian
denominations in over 300 churches
across New Hampshire we are called to
uphold the Dignity of work the value of
solidarity and the pursuit of justice
for all scripture repeatedly calls us to
protect the rights of workers and to
ensure they are treated with fairness
and respect the Book of James warns
against withholding Fair compensation
from laborers the wages of the laborers
who mowed your fields which you kept
back by fraud cry out and the cries of
the Harvesters have reached the ears of
the Lord of
hosts right to work laws risk silencing
these cries by weakening the collective
voice of workers making it harder for
them to advocate for just wages safe
working conditions and the dignity they
deserve as Christians we are also called
to Bear one another's burdens and work
for the common good unions embody this
principle of
solidarity providing workers with the
strength that comes from standing
together make no mistake HB 238
undermines this solidarity it Fosters
Division and creates economic
instability for families and
communities by diminishing the power of
workers to negotiate
collectively this legislation threatens
not just to harm
individuals but the moral fabric of New
Hampshire lastly our faith compels us to
prioritize the well-being of the
vulnerable data indicates as you've
heard that these laws often result in
lower wages and reduced benefits
disproportionately impacting those who
are already struggling to make ends meet
we are called to create a society where
everyone has the opportunity to
thrive again the New Hampshire Council
of UR churches urges you to vote itl on
HB
questions seeing no questions thank you
Tran thank you and on Deck we have Ron
Wade on
Deck can we testify
together uh please identify yourselves
hosana tahun and Rowan Wade oh you're
together yes we're from the same
organization okay absolutely and on Deck
uh Larry Marin and you have 3 minutes
okay thank you honorable chairman and
distinguished state representatives my
name is hosana tahun a union secretary
and Senior at Dartmouth College I'm also
a dining worker and daughter of an ATU
Local 689 bus driver from
DC hi my name is Rowan Wade I'm a junior
at Dartmouth College I work several jobs
to get by I'm the vice chair of our
Union and also lifelong Union member my
no problem we could do that that's thank
that thank you oh thank you so our Union
is called the student workers Collective
at Dartmouth and we were established in
2022 we were the fifth undergraduate
labor union to emerge in the United
States and we are here in strong
opposition to this Right to Work bill
between my freshman and sophomore years
of college our independent student Le
Union was able to negotiate a platform
of workplace benefits to secure all
undergraduate dining employees at $21
base wage and sick pay our union dues
are just 2% which is 2 cents for every
dollar um and they go towards
supplementing our hardship fund and
sourcing legal support as we bargain
against our 8 billion doll institutions
lawyers our wages were raised 40% and
through our on the ground organizing
effort efforts uh we were able to
increase it from just earning 12 to
$21 um and to this day our dues only
take a fraction of our paycheck but they
Chang the trajectory of every single
worker at Dartmouth
College yeah I think it's really
important to note that before our Union
formed at our College just two years ago
we often as low-income students felt
like we were workers first and students
second that our purpose was to serve our
more affluent peers um when I first got
to college before we had a union I was
working upwards of 40 hours a week I was
choosing my classes around my work
schedule instead of the other way around
the union has dramatically impacted our
ability to be students and to be members
of our community um I think it's also
really critical to understand that dues
are a very very small fraction of our
paycheck compared to the benefits we get
when we unionized if you deduct the 2%
in do is that go towards supporting our
Union which is an independent Union it
is Rank and file Leed we as student
workers are the ones doing all the
support work to keep it going filing the
Grievances negotiating with the
college's lawyers who make more money
than we'll ever see and it is really
important to know that that is a 38% net
increase in wages on top of that we got
more benefits like sick pay and mental
health pay and so this idea that people
are at risk of losing money when they
are obligated to pay dues for Union
representation does not play out in
reality I think um another note is that
our dues um which are democratically
ladies that's uh your time is up subject
to any questions representative Granger
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions so was the Dartmouth
Hitchcock Union in any way involved with
the decision by uh Dartmouth K Hitchcock
to deny kidney transplants to those who
refuse the Corona virus shots
we do not represent um medical workers
at all we represent student dining
workers and undergraduate advisers
completely different unions thank you
very much any other
questions
see repr FL again uh thank you Mr
chairman I I again I apologize did you
represented your own Union you
established your own Union Yes um when
we initially founded it were we were the
fifth ever undergraduate Union it was
considered very
risky to take on students as a labor
force and so we are an independently
formed Union we are Rank and file L we
teach ourselves contract law between
classes just a quick followup what's the
name of your union the student worker
Collective at Dartmouth thank
you ladies thank you very much and uh
very very good work thank you so much
thank
McCarthy morning uh my name is Larry
moochin I'm here on behalf of the over
200 uh uh 2,000 Union laborers who
reside in New Hampshire I'm also a
resident of Bo um one of the arguments
in favor of right to work is that uh
Union uh the employees should be able to
choose where they work without having to
join the union I would implore you to
examine that argument a little more
closely the question is why are the
employers that are unionized so
attractive uh to work for could it be
that the union that uh represents these
uh workers so well and negotiates for
their interests
um that the members that work at these
places the pay and benefits are superior
to the competitor employees which may
not be
organized um secondly right to work is
really the endorsement of getting
something for nothing which is
essentially is welfare for employees who
earn the exact same thing as the person
working next to them the only difference
is that the person working next to them
is paying for their share of the
negotiated
contract uh from the services and the
benefits and working conditions and
wages that the union has provided for
them through
negotiations and the concept of paying
dues for services is in benefits is not
a novel concept organizations that
support this legislation right here like
the ABC and the BR are Do's member uh
based
organizations it would be very
interesting to know if either would
provide their services to those who are
non-members even if those non-members
would like to get the benefit of those
Services um the final question is what
problem is this trying to solve here in
New Hampshire we already have as low as
you can pay 725 minimum wage we have one
of the lowest unemployment rates in the
country um and we have no prevailing
wages on construction projects already
this is all the things that right to
work did in other states um this leads
me to the inevitable conclusion that the
purpose of this bill is for the
government to infringe on the rights of
two private entities trying to negotiate
a contract to provide goods and services
for employees that they mutually agreed
on um that's my testimony I urge you to
please vote to recommend House Bill 238
as inexpedient to
legislate thank you for your testimony
any
questions seeing
none uh thank you sir I appreciate you
coming in
Deck good morning Mr sorry U Mr chairman
and members of the committee I
appreciate the opportunity to speak here
today my name is Michael McCarthy I was
a for term state representative from
NASA a 26- year member of the IBEW labor
union and a 31-year member of the
Republican party to expand on what some
other people said here today there are
consequences of right to work and I
think particularly when we're talking
about something that you might not have
personal background in having been in a
union I'd compare it to um instead of
Labor dues the fees one pays into a
homeowners association or into a condo
association now the reason people live
in these associations is because they
want someone to mow the lawn to remove
the snow to clean the pool to do
maintenance now some people choose not
to live in these places despite wanting
these benefits because they don't want
to pay them now if we were to pass a law
that uh said that it was okay to live in
a condo association or homeowners
association but get all the benefits and
pay nothing in those associations would
go bankrupt that is a consequence of
right to work as far as I'm concerned um
now strictly speaking as a republican
it's a frustrating issue because it's
like Groundhog Day this issue keeps
coming up over and over and over again
um
and uh is the Republican party has run
the state of New Hampshire for the most
part since the Civil War and this is an
issue that has been coming up in this
state as I understand it since
1947 that means time again over and over
again when this issue has been voted
down it's been under a house that's been
controlled by Republicans under a senate
controlled by Republicans and under
Republican Governor so she didn't even
become part of our party platform until
2010 now during my time as a legislature
we had uh fight this issue in two
contentious times during the um 2010 and
the 2016 session now sad to say we
started out in a in a majority and
particularly the 2010 session it was a
super majority now the after effects of
this of us pursuing this issue in an
illc conceived fashion was a much less
in uh spectacular minority position and
I just think people are expressing
themselves at The Ballot Box this issue
is not popular among the people of New
Hampshire and I believe uh it's a
negative consequence for the people of
New Hampshire when Republicans aren't in
charge of the state that's my personal
perspective uh just to Simply wrap up um
since 1947 we've had a tremendous um
tradition of finding right to work and
expedient to legislate in the state
state of Hampshire and I ask the
committee to please uphold this
tradition and again find right toic and
expedient to legislate uh to move things
along no questions thank you all right
thank you sir you're welcome appreciate
your
testimony and I'd like to call B barudi
please and on Deck is representative
David
love good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee uh my name is Ben Broody
former representative for 32 years
member of this committee for I think 12
terms so I've heard it all and I'm sure
you're going to hear it all over again
today
um I'm here representing myself cuz
today I'm a realtor and I'm having
served on the affordable housing
committee and being a realtor uh we know
of the housing crisis and what's going
on and now is not a good time for us to
weaken our Workforce taking benefits
away from workers as a previous speaker
said um people want good solid workers
with benefits they can afford to pay
rent and so for
um I can't stop but think about what
unions do for people um I got a
granddaughter who um during Co worked in
a hospital she came home with Co gave it
to her my my grand great-grandson so she
had to quit that profession it was
pretty H hard on both of them she lost a
lot of time out of work and then she
became EX exuse me a union Apprentice
Carpenter now she's making good money
with Benefits
Insurance she can pay for her own
insurance she can stand on her own two
feet and hold her head up
high dignity and um she's doing good in
fact next week for the whole entire week
she goes to school she goes to school to
learn how to be a good
Carpenter I can buy a tool belt and put
a hammer in it and call myself a
carpenter and come and rip you off when
you hire me to do a job union carpenters
are professionals they do a good job and
you never have to call them back to fix
what they
did I know that um when I was a young
man and I joined the army I remember
being in boot camp down at Forex New
Jersey the first thing you're taught is
a chain of command and you have to
respect your chain of command and just
do what they say so having gone through
that one thing is the top of that chain
of command is the
commander-in-chief well as of Monday we
got a new
commander-in-chief not everybody likes
that a lot of people are upset he's
still our commanderin-chief
and I had to listen to his speech on
Monday and in his speech he surprised me
with something he said he said he won
seven Battleground States all seven he
said I did it with the help of the
unions the unions steep forward the
unions in
Detroit they came in and help him win
Michigan he praised people in Detroit he
mentioned the teamsters he mentioned the
Carpenters and there's one I don't F out
oh the
firefighters so they took him over the
top so representative that's your three
minutes representative Granger
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do any of the unions
that you mentioned actually endorse
Donald Trump for
president I don't know for sure and I'm
sure that there's a lot of people and he
knows who was supporting him and he
didn't he mentioned him if you listen to
his speech he named them he called them
out by name that took him over the top
if you want to listen to inaugural
speech all right and let's stay to the
subject of HB 238 please
thank you any further questions
representative k Mr chair thank you uh
honorable Ben barudi for taking my
question uh you mentioned that your
granddaughter is getting training to be
a skilled Carpenter and I I would have
asked the prior speaker who in the IID
ibw which I understand that that
electrical union teaches electricians
which I can't find one to do some work I
need on my house U but
uh that that training and the skill set
is is it correct that you know when you
when you see a union a union worker you
don't have to say look for somebody says
I can do it cheaper which is a scary
phrase if we know
better well cheaper is not always better
exactly you know you get for what you
pay that's what I always say thank you
all right any other further
questions representative L thank you Mr
chair representative how much does um
your granddaughter pay to go to the
schooling nothing thank you and any
other follow-ups seeing no
questions oh I'm sorry representative
Sullivan is it true that that uh
schooling is actually provided by the
union yes it is fully fully funded by
the unions thank you train and the
teachers are trained professional
Carpenters okay now seeing no further
questions thank you sir I appreciate
your testimony thank you for your
service
okay and uh representative
representative David love please and on
Deck uh Peggy
Murphy thank you Mr chair members of the
the labor committee uh my name is
representative David love uh
representing the town of Derry
Rockingham 13 it's my fourth term I
served on this committee the last two
last two terms um uh a little little
history on me I was born into a family
my my my grandfather was a charter
member of Teamster local local 25 his
name's on the charter U my father was a
lifelong Teamster my mother's past
president of one of the local uh the ibw
locals uh born you know born right into
a union uh household I've probably
learned more about uh contract
negotiations and stuff at the kitchen
table and most people will ever know but
um I'd never I'd never support anything
that stops someone from joining a
union and what we're what we're looking
at here is uh stopping somebody from not
joining a union and I wouldn't support
that either you know um the personal
Liberty is is what uh what What's
driving me you know uh a little more of
my own history I I in 1974 I joined the
teamsters myself I was working for a
liquor distributor uh we had a um a
business agent that went out and and uh
you know he he drank his lunch with the
with the bosses three times a week uh
and came back and when we needed him he
was nowhere to be found
and um you know it would have been nice
to be able to say no Mr business agent
I'm not paying the dues this month until
you start doing your job we couldn't do
that okay um like I said I I I wouldn't
I don't want to support anybody from not
joining a union to me a union is is like
any other business it's like Triple A
you know if do you want the service or
don't you you know do do you want the
benefits or don't you uh if you if you
don't want to buy in you sure shouldn't
have to buy in it's like going out and
buying a if I went up to Motorcycles of
Manchester and bought a new Holly
Davidson do I have to join the Hell's
Angels you know it's it's no different
okay um you know um we need to protect
everybody's rights here and and to me
it's a it's a it's a liberty a liberty
issue you know I I'd never deny all the
benefits of uh of being a union member
of I've had them in my own life you know
I helped organized a a a a bus company
in London der uh a long time ago 10 12
years ago I think it was but um you know
uh um I Am pro Union but I'm also prol
Liberty and and and that's the question
here you know are we are we going to
force people to do anything I I say no
and I urge you to vote um vote about the
pass on
this great thank you for your testimony
any
questions see no questions sir thank you
for your time and thank you for your
testimony
oh okay um sir can you please take the
stand again I'm sorry representative
McKenzie I did not see your hand not a
problem that's sorry I'll
raise um good to see you again
representative uh and I've heard your
story before uh you've come before this
committee the question I have is when
you mentioned that nothing you could do
about how your union was being
run uh it's my understanding that the
members run the union not the boss runs
the union but the members so isn't it
true that you could at
Anytime work within your union to do
what you think was best for your union
because you've said that you had no
control over
that the problem there being and
somebody has mentioned it uh you know
the difference between a democracy in a
in a constitutional republic uh the in a
democracy and that's what unions are you
know you've got 500 members and you've
got one guy with a complaint well 500
members rule okay uh in uh in this case
that you can say you can resign from a
union if if this this bill passes you
can say no I've had enough of this
you're not serving me well I don't like
your service I don't like your product
okay whether you and and if that's the
way you feel you don't have to pay you
know you don't have to be you don't have
to be a member okay and uh otherwise and
back back in 1974 I you know I I know we
had laws but those laws were being
broken I wish I had a copy of the
contract who it was mandated that you
join the union and I know people that
were were were let go you know we we had
a a thing where um we you had to work 96
hours in in 30 days and um you know then
you then you had to join the union and I
know people that will let go because
they didn't want to join the union you
know back in 1974 1975 in that time
period
okay any other questions representative
Sullivan you repeatedly say you had to
join the union yes are you fully aware
that it is illegal to force someone to
join a
union I am but in 1974 that's what they
were doing uh you know whether it was
illegal or not it was in that contract
like I said I wish I had a c copy of
that contract it was in there you know
must join power up yes sir um you also
mentioned that you were very
dissatisfied with uh your union rep yes
I was a union rep for 25 years it was my
job to make sure the members were well
taken care
of part of what motivated me was I
didn't want to have a complaint go to my
boss because my boss would have dealt
with that complaint and I would have
been you know brought in the carpet I'm
proud to say it for 25 years that I had
no
complaints um
and I was proud of the work I did but if
there's somebody who's not doing their
job
um they ought to be um um have a
complaint I ask you did you file a
complaint filing a complaint complaint
back in those days to get you
blackballed okay uh you you'd get no
representation you'd uh you the first at
the first uh little bit of little bit of
okay yes sir um I I have a follow-up
question and I think it's important in
the sense that
um try to figure out when people
withdraw from a union uh how this would
work and okay I would like to know
so the current situation is that
everybody gets the same benefits whether
you a member of the union or not so if
you withdraw from the union you
disconnect completely from the union now
I'm the employer so could you explain to
me how that would work if we had 50
different people uh you had the union
they had people that were just
Independents within that organization
how would that work and how would the
boss or the owner of that company manage
that kind of
situation well I imagine they'd be able
to um you know hire fire pay better
better benefits on on on on Merit if
you've got a super employee you pay him
if the guy's a slug well that has to be
reflective in in how he's uh how he's
too so you're you're saying that you
would have individual agreements so
you'd have the Union contract then you
would have individual agreements with
those people who wanted to be uh didn't
want to be part of the union and yes and
you is at your position that that would
promote labor peace within an
organization or would that be disruptive
to an
organization whether it promoted labor
peace or not uh it would promote labor
labor
Liberty okay thank you Mr chairman thank
you sir all right thank you appreciate
your testimony
representative and now like to call
Peggy
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee and happy New Year to you
all my name is Peggy Murphy McCarthy and
I live in Nashua I am a member of ibw
local 2320 in Manchester a former member
of the New Hampshire house and I'm a
republican my fellow Union Republicans
and I have had a challenging time in New
Hampshire we've never understood the
Republican disdain for unions aren't we
all about limiting government
interference I took my job 28 years ago
specifically because it had a union
I benefit from good wages Health Care
retirement safe work rules paid medical
leave and pay Equity those are six major
labor issues that were negotiated not
legislated this bill attempts to insert
government into an existing functioning
private Arrangement it suggests that
union workers are victims in need of
Rescue by the state worker freedom is
just a clever rebranding of the rhetoric
we heard in 2010 that this bill would
break the back of organized labor it's
been a tough 15 years for sure much to
our surprise in July president Trump
chose for his running mate a senator who
had walked a UAW picket line with his
striking constituents and then in August
the New Hampshire GOP chair announced an
effort to reach out to Union Republicans
stating that we and I quote were no
longer the
opposition after the election President
Trump selected for his labor secretary
Lori Chavez deer a union endorsed
Republican congresswoman who
co-sponsored the proa that news got
everyone's attention president Trump's
slogan has been make America great again
and I've seen many posts reflecting on
how previous generations could support a
family own a home and retire on one
salary many of those grandparents I
would submit to you were union members
in the mid1 1950s union membership was
at its peak at about 35% of the
workforce and our economy was thriving
as the labor plank of the 1956
Republican platform stated end I quote
the process of free collective
bargaining has been strengthened by the
insistence of this Administration that
labor and management settle their
differences at the bargaining table
without the intervention of the
government President Eisenhower was
quoted labor is the United States the
men and women who create the wealth that
is shared in this country they are
America I truly hope the Outreach this
summer was not in bad faith
members of the committee we cannot make
America great again without giving those
who built this country the respect and
support they deserve and have earned we
keep the power on we keep you online we
keep you safe warm and connected and we
get you where you need to be labor makes
Prosperity possible we are doing our
part please do yours by recommending
this bill in expedient to legislate
thank you thank you representative
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
questions
you suggest that right to work
represents government interference but
what could be a greater interference
than the federal government stripping
away non members right to bargain for
themselves or to represent themselves in
a
grievance could you repeat that you
suggest that right to work represents
government interference but what could
be a greater interference than the
federal government stripping away
non-members right to bargain for
themselves or to represent themselves in
a
grievance I don't see that as government
interference if they're in an agreed
upon arrangement to work in this office
to work in this shop to work wherever
this work location is Under the Umbrella
of their collective bargaining agreement
that if something comes up that they
have a grievance they will be
represented by the union if they want to
represent themselves they can work
someplace
else all right uh follow up keep it as
questions please do you think that the
federal government should be involved in
forcing people out of their job if they
do not want to join a
union no no but that's not what this
is
okay representive Schultz thank you Mr
chair I just would like to request a
copy of her speech that she seems to
have written I have this one messy one
can I submit a PDF to the committee yes
ma'am thank
you like well you represented the plan
Miss Peggy Murphy Oh that okay I got
yeah all right uh Miss Pamela Ian yes
Hayward thank you Mr chair and I want to
thank the committee my name is Pamela
Ian I live in conquered and I strongly
support this bill this bill is one of
Liberty and freedom and since New
Hampshire is the Live Free or Die state
workers should have the freedom to
choose whether to Jo join a union or not
and never be subjected to agency fees
now much of what I was going to discuss
has already been mentioned um so I'm
going to keep this brief um I've heard
that government should not be involved
in an organization which has the
blessings of government through the
national Relations Act of 1935 as
representative Granger just pointed out
unions are forced
to provide collective bargaining for
anybody that's in that particular job
first of all I don't see anything in the
Constitution that gave the government
the right to do this um so as far as I'm
concerned they the government created
the problem and unfortunately it'll be
up to government to rectify the problem
by making right to
work now I've heard arguments that claim
that without Union
representation that chaos would ensue
when it became time for worker
contracts in my younger days I was a
police officer in the state of Texas
which is a right to work
state there were never any problems with
negotiation whether it be with salary or
benefits employees and employers can
work together without labor unions
representation and it is the right and
to me it's very insulting that a
government agency would think that I is
am uncapable of negotiating for what I
need for myself and my family and as
I've stated in Texas we did not have any
problem um I I heard one representative
say that uh there would be a lot of
different contracts this was not the
case and it isn't today because as I
said Texas is still a right to work
state
so I implore you to pass this important
Bill thank you thank you for your
testimony representative Schulz thank
you Mr chair quick question were you a
member of a union in Texas and are you a
member of a union currently um no Texas
was is a well back then I don't know if
there was right to work or not but we
were not a unionized police force in the
city of Marshall
Texas and I was forced pay agency
fees when I was a teacher here in New
Hampshire
um fortunately I was able to get a
religious exemption but then when I they
told me I would have to pay that $400
$500 to a charity they wouldn't let me
pick a charity that I would use so again
I was being forced to do something that
I shouldn't have had to do with my own
hard-earned
money and luckily when the Janice
decision came by I no longer had to
abide by that rule but unfortunately a
lot of people in the private sector will
still have to do this and as I said and
I'm going to reiterate this again
government created this problem in
1935 and hopefully we can get rid of it
here in New Hampshire thank
representative McKenzie thank you Mr
chairman thank you for appearing before
the committee uh you were a union
teacher at one point is that your
testimony I was not a member of the
Union ever um but 10 years into my
teaching here in New Hampshire um they
decided that I had to pay the agency fee
and I was able to say no because of
religious affiliations which I had to
prove and then they told me I couldn't
give my money to a religious
organization all I don't so the question
I have is for a followup sir sure as a
non-union member m did you receive the
benefit benefits that were negotiated by
the union and did you take those
benefits that were negotiated by the
union to which you did not contribute to
the to the administration of that thing
did you did you take all the benefits of
course just like I did in Texas when I
was not a member of a union thank you
representative
farington thank you Mr chairman as a
non-member did the Union ever Advocate
against your own interest
yes by taking my money I'm a single
parent and every scent
counted okay repr stop thank you Mr
chair um did you ever consider going to
work for a nonpublic school during that
time yes I did but as a single parent uh
I considered going to the one of the
Catholic schools and um
unfortunately since Vatican 2 came out
it's it's very hard to uh for teachers
to have the same salary as public school
or private schools I see so the money
was better in the public school yeah it
would have also been better in a private
school other than Catholic all right
thank you all right represent bashard
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question okay right to work allows
workers to benefit from Union
negotiations without paying dues
how can you assure me of the fairness of
some employees receiving the benefit of
collective bargaining for free While
others bear the cost okay as I've stated
the federal government created this
problem and two wrongs don't make a
right it is up to this body for the
citizens of New Hampshire to tell the
federal government we're not doing that
and there's been a lot of federal laws
that are not right are not
constitutional and they need to be
challenged okay representative kale
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh just to clarify do I did
I hear correctly that the job you had as
a union teacher paid better wages and
benefits than was available to you in a
non-union School in a Catholic school
and that's where I am a Catholic and I
was I considered working there in
conquered because I am a single parent
uh now I might have been able to go to
some private school somewhere else but
then I would have had to travel been
away from my kids
more for a followup so so it was better
in your situation as a single parent uh
to stay working with the Union teaching
job teaching in the school where I was
yes but as I said it was wrong for the
law in 19 1935 to prevent me from
negotiating okay so it's like a it's
like a catch 22 there one more small one
small B this is this is but again I'm
yes not
interrogation right okay okay but again
because of the Union negotiated wages
and benefits that you had even minus the
agency fee that I agree un you did did
not like paying your your situation was
was better than going
elsewhere I'm not going to say it was
because of the Union because there's a
lot of places where people work and they
get
[Music]
benefits all right Ram Schultz Mr chair
I'd like to take a point of personal
privilege if it's okay and by that I
mean I want to correct an important I
also am Catholic and the and the bishop
here in Manchester strongly opposes
right to work as does the pope as does
the US Conference of Bishops that is
among the values in my family that is
not part of wanted to correct that it
the Catholic church that's is not part
of testimony thank you further
questions seeing none thank you ma'am
for your testimony I appreciate you
coming and talking to us thank you sir
thank
you point of order representative flan
thank you these people are coming out
probably a little bit intimidated being
here in conquer but let's not intim
let's not put them through the the
ringer here let's take their testimony
listen to what they have to say thank
him for coming noted this is not
interrogation this is trying to
understand what's going on with HB 238
thank you so much appreciate your
cooperation Mark Hayward next on Deck
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the labor committee my name is Mark
Hayward I live in Manchester and I'm am
a retired member of the New Hampshire
news Guild and also a member organizer
with that group um uh I'm coming here to
address this myth of um this worker
who's out there and is stranded and has
no recourse because he she is in a union
um unions are democratic small D
Democratic organizations they um they
run elections and if you're unhappy um
you're in this Union you're unhappy with
things let's you don't like the work
rules you want Merit pay you want um uh
you want it you want it you the uh the
business agent is drinking too much like
someone said well what do you do you do
everything that you people have done
you run and you change things is it hard
yes right um you've got to convince
people you got to put your name out
there um I admire you guys whether I
agree with you or not every two years
you go you you work you know you you go
and you run and you get elected because
you want to change things
um yeah right right well I think unions
do a little better than $100 a year um
and uh yeah
um that's that's really I I I never hear
that point brought out enough that that
you can change things um that I I work
for a union and I've done some
organizing um or organizing work on a on
a renewal contract both of those had
Merit pay so um I I and I think that's a
trend at least in the news Guild is to
have have Merit pay in in um in Union
contracts so um any other questions any
question appreciate your testimony thank
you representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question what would you say to the
workers who do not wish to engage in
increased levels of workplace
politics um you can you can you mean you
mean donating to political campaigns or
well you mentioned that or followup so
you mentioned that
um you can change things right through a
similar through a similar method that we
use to get become representatives for
$100 a year yeah so what would you say
to those workers who do not want wish to
have more workplace politics I I guess
then then whatever their concern is
important I I think the analogy is I
live in Manchester but you know what and
and I like and I get police coverage
fire coverage my roads are plowed um but
you know what I don't want to pay taxes
so I just won't vote and everything will
be fine that's just not how it works in
this
country for a
followup would you consider union dues a
sort of
tax uh yes and agency fees and agency
fees sure thank you very much yeah okay
any other
questions thank you thank you sir for
your testimony I appreciate it thank you
representative uh
Eden oh thank you very much Mr chairman
and thank you for getting my name right
the second time I had a funny experience
in the Senate once which was uh the
chair kept saying representative
Harrington representative Harrington
who's another rep from stford County and
I thought it I was looking around for
Michael Harrington and she realized I
thought I'd written my name clearly
enough but I apparently I didn't but I
apologize so I'm resident Timothy Horgan
h o r r i g- n and um I'm from straford
County District 10 the town of Durham
and
um the phrase right to work is
misleading obviously work is a privilege
not a right I mean everybody deserves
the opportunity to work but nobody's
entitled to any particular job with any
particular
employer and um every employer does have
the right to set the terms of the
employment and if you want to work for
that employer you need to meet those
terms and some employers have chosen to
be Union shops and
um and obviously that usually doesn't
happen 100% voluntarily they usually
unionize only if the workers get
together to organize a union which is
pretty difficult but every employer has
the right to get by with non-union labor
to move their existing facilities
somewhere else including to North
Carolina or overseas or even the shut
down altogether so I'm in my ninth term
now I've been getting letters snail mail
letters delivered by unionized postal
workers from New England write to work
for over 15 years now and I haven't
saved all those letters I do have that
20 and 20 2013 letters and they both say
exactly the same thing as as a 2025
letter and one of their talking points
is repeated reference to a report by PHS
fantas the nation's longtime leading
business relocation firm and um that
firm actually hasn't existed for 20
years and it's I have good reason to
believe that that report doesn't in fact
does not actually exist and if they did
they were a consulting firm that was
selling a particular version to business
climate and one of the things
and what they thought was a good
business climate was a non-union
Workforce but that's uh that's just that
was just their opinion and ironically
they don't exist anymore because they
got bought up by a large company which
sold them to another large company and
that's something I'm sure the workers of
that company lost their jobs in that
process and so about 2005 it disappeared
all together but
um and uh so you have my written
testimony which you've seen twice cuz I
handed out copies and put it on the
portal but anyway unions and I'm still
lifting a phrase here from Mark from
Mark Hayward just testified they're
small D Democratic
institutions they're not perfect but
they're more democratic than many other
institutions so any union members
dissatisfied with the Union's
performance is this free to work with
the Union committee they're also um free
to go somewhere else um they're if the
pay rates working diss are better
somewhere else they can go somewhere
else but
usually fact almost always those pay
rates and working conditions are better
when the workers can collectively
negotiate through the union and if some
worker doesn't want anything at all to
do with unions just about every
profession has a choice of non-union
shops and representative your time is up
all right thank you are there any
questions sure thanks see no question
it I'd like to call Tom Eden
colb hello chair and representatives
good morning sir my name is Tom Eaton
I'm a lifelong New Hampshire resident
and proud ibw member I'm here
representing myself I testified my
opposition to the right to work Senate
Bill 516 on March 19th 2024 I focused on
the statistics obain obtained by
Vermont's 2024 proposition 3 the
proposition passed the Vermont House and
Senate Senate
unanimously this sent a strong message
to Vermont's middle class their elected
officials support them and not corporate
lobbyists pushing a Washington DC agenda
on in our region there are still no
right to work states in New England to
date and we should keep it that way we
are here today to oppose Right to Work
House Bill 238 Right to Work always has
been and always will be be wrong for New
Hampshire there is nothing about right
to work that makes our state a better
place to work or live the effects of
Right to Work are quite the opposite in
states where it has been voted in right
to work is not beneficial to workers its
only purpose is to weaken unions from
within by financial distress the name
right to work is quite deceiving no
labor unions wish unemployment for
workers we feel the exact opposite we
want the safest best workplaces and
practices
we can
achieve union jobs are more attractive
to workers because of the compensation
benefits and retirement that are
collectively bargained for unions are
voted into shops and workplaces under
nlrb guidelines and procedures by a
majority vote of the employees if
someone does not wish to work at a union
shop they are free to work at a
non-union shop that performs the same
job I compel you all to think who this
legislation serves it does not benefit
the people of New Hampshire it intends
to diminish our quality of life for the
profit of others please help send the
message to New Hampshire voters that our
elected officials support our middle
class bluecollar workers and not the
Washington DC corporate lobbyist pushing
this agenda please find HB 238 in
expediate to legislate thank you for
your time thank you thank you for your
seeing none thank you sir I appreciate
in I'd like to call John C please and on
Deck will be Christen
Bowen okay uh Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is John
calb and I'm vice president of the
national Right to Work committee and a
resident of Berlin New Hampshire um on
behalf of our many members and
supporters here in New Hampshire I urge
you to support House Bill 238 the New
Hampshire Right to Work bill of course a
number of other people are going to be
talking about the economic arguments in
favor of right to work which are very
real um the fact is over the last decade
right to work states saw 16% job growth
while New Hampshire lagged behind at 5 a
half% uh Kentucky in 2017 pass right to
work in January went into effect
immediately and they added 100,000 jobs
saw $9.2 billion in investment from in
in new projects their previous high was
5.5 billion um the you know Oklahoma
went from 40th in job growth the first
almost immediately and stayed in the top
five over the next decade Indiana dozens
of projects in the pipeline within eight
months of right to work you know you it
works um West Virginia lost jobs in the
six years leading up to right to work
6,000 jobs if I remember right added
22,000 in the three years after it
passed it and they recovered from you
the losses for covid way faster than Mo
most other states um the reason for this
is something like half of all states
considering relocation or expansion uh
automatically rule out non-right to work
states but you know the ranger of my
time I'd just like to talk a little
about you some of the arguments you're
likely to hear um yeah as you know tens
of thousands of workers in New Hampshire
presently have no choice you know if
they're you they're forced to pay union
dues or not have a job and Common Sense
tells us that no private organization
should be able to take away a worker's
livelihood for refusal to bankroll that
organization and and Common Sense also
tells us freedom is two-sided that's why
the First Amendment bars Congress from
prohibiting religious observance and
also bars Congress from forcing anyone
to worship um same principle should
apply in labor law freedom to associate
is meaningless without you know Freedom
not to associate yet Right to Work
opponents claim a worker who wants to
join Union somehow isn't truly free
unless all his co-workers pay up um you
there are several rationalizations for
this the first is that they're forced to
pay you know represent non-members as
several people have said that's just not
true in the private in the private
sector quote William g Who was appointed
by Bill Clinton to serve as chairman of
the nlrb um in his book agenda reform he
said the law permits members only
bargaining without regard to majority
rule or an appropriate unit without
regard to exclusivity the fact is you
know exclusive representation is the
something the union bosses demand not
something that is foisted on them second
rationalization is on this false
assumption that working that that
workers you know all workers benefit I
mean it's a simple example here in New
Hampshire was in 2009 the state of
employees Association refused to
negotiate fur law lows and as a result
250 workers who were then forced to pay
union dues at the time lost their jobs
you know those workers lost their jobs
as a direct result of the Union's
negotiating strategy please tell me how
those workers benefit from Union
membership indeed then California
attorney general okay I'm up I'll
stop thank you so much representative
Granger never mind
Roger representative St
please um you gave us a lot of data can
I ask where that data came from and can
you provide it to us uh yes I can um
with with regards to the specifics uh
most of it comes from just Federal you
know employment data combined with uh we
typ we typically use uh The Merck uh
cost of living dat you know uh index but
uh yeah I can get it right over all
right thank you thank you sir
representative
Flanagan thank you Mr Mr chairman you
had mentioned West Virginia MH and I
think all of us received an email of a
video that Governor Justice put out
saying that they enacted right to work
and no one was beating down his door to
bring their businesses to West Virginia
and I'm just
wondering how does that the data that
you had saying they had Monumental
growth uh compared to what he testified
or stated in a state of the uh the state
address I would imagine that's what it
was um so so representative Flanigan I I
know that you've probably seen a
dishonest attack ad in politics once or
twice in your life um yeah it it people
in this room have seen them a lot um
probably about them uh in any event um
you know before he said that Governor
Justice made it clear he supported right
to work and he cautioned against
twisting his words I mean the fact is
what he was saying in context Is that
West Virginia hadn't done enough I mean
in 2019 Justice came out and said that
yeah right to work was a reason why they
were adding jobs but after Co I mean
look you know uh he he's a guy who wants
the state to be better um and you know
that and so yeah he's looking to do more
to advocate for a state understandable
but anyway you have another question
okay just for a followup it the video
was of him yes is I mean I don't know
how you could put words in his mouth
when it comes out of his mouth that he
was doing a state but anyway got thank
yeah um representative labry and then
represent Schultz thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh the
North country is economically challenged
and what do you think that this law ped
would do to that North Country near and
dear to my heart is a Berlin guy um yeah
I think it would help I mean it would
get you know so a right to work you know
what what the what the old Fanta study
says and what most of these other
studies say is that it's a primary
selection criteria for half of companies
so they're not even looking at non-right
to work states it's kind of of like if
you're looking for real estate and you
need a house you know you're only
looking at houses with a garage or
something and you know your right to
work is kind of like a free garage I
mean unlike a lot of other Economic
Development things I mean um you know a
company that insists on an interstate
highway coming to their town is not
going to cons consider Berlin but it is
going to get them more looks and it'll
and it'll help them get it'll help them
hopefully close out a few jobs and get
some real Prosperity up
there follow uh for a followup
thank you Mr chair
um I guess not only in my opinion but in
the opinion of a lot of folks there's a
lot of union jobs in the North Country
whether it's uh prisons systems or or
whatnot um and it still remains
depressed how do you square that so
you're asking me why there are a lot
there are a lot of union jobs and why
the area is depressed look a lot of
companies have moved out I mean and and
they never got replaced I mean Berlin
had a population over 20,000 in the
1920s and it's down I think 9,000 right
now um
you know it's just you know the package
of you know you know you logging has
move you know has gotten smaller and
paper mills and um they just really
hasn't been you know they they sold the
prisons as a way of you know bringing
other employment but you know it it just
hasn't been enough and I'd like to see
more come into the North Country thank
you okay and repres Schultz thank you Mr
chair I should have held this question
for you given your affiliation um why do
you think the national
GOP uh platform under Donald Trump
removed the right to work um plank so
there are a lot of things they took out
of the platform I mean if you look at
the 2024 platform it's a much simpler
sort of overall overarching statement of
principles rather than a a bill of
specifics and they just you know they
took a you number of issues unrelated to
right to work out of the platform it's
just it's a much simpler document you
know you have less words you say
less okay and represent McKenzie sir and
representative Sol on De uh you had a
lot to say during the course of this
testimony and it's very difficult to
unpack it uh but let me say one thing uh
that the North Country for many many
years was wall to wall unions up there
and it was a failure of uh and the
economy changed and the the Mills closed
but that that aside this particular bill
as I as I read it has two Visions in it
one is uh relates to becoming uh a
remain a union
member uh which currently is a
jurisdiction of the of the federal
government so this has no real impact
that people currently can can join a
union or not join a union they can come
to work in a in a there's no such thing
as a union shop anymore but they can
come to work in any business in the
state of no Hampshire union or non-union
and do not have to currently uh uh
they're not prohibited from doing that
do we agree on that that that is one
provision of this well you misspoke sir
the union shop is not prohibited but the
the closed shop is prohibited but yeah
um but yeah and the problem is that
workers are still being forced to pay a
union as a condition of employment and
we consider that wrong so Mr chairman is
that's the point of this this
legislation there's a lot of other stuff
included in it but it comes down to that
second section that's number two which
basically says it's about paying union
dues it's about paying agency fees
correct because it's not going to change
in terms of people's access to to
employment well I do think it's
important to reiterate a worker's right
to join a union if they so choose you
know I think that's important
philosophically but yeah no I I mean but
yeah obviously you know the teeth of the
bill or forcing is that it eliminates
the practice of forcing workers to join
or support a
union okay and representative Sullivan
sir representative McKenzie did a good
job of taking my
thunder okay representative
rer uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question is a non-union
member who is forced to pay union dues
allowed to vote in the union no thank
you and representative Susi and then
representative ler thank you Mr chairman
so I see you wearing the orange badge do
you represent you represent right to
work yes I'm an employee of the national
Right to Work committee do you receive a
fee or a paycheck to do that yeah I'm
I'm an employe okay so my question would
be you're representing the national
right to work and you charge them a fee
you get a paycheck why should unions
have to represent people and not get
paid to do it as well they've demanded
that power under federal law I I mean
this isn't something foed on them it's
something they've demanded that's a
clear difference
okay and representative lerk thank you
Mr chair um I would have to agree with
you that 80% of the people that live in
New Hampshire support people's ability
of to have the right to
work do you believe that they understand
the legislation and would agree with it
if they knew really what it
was basically a union
busting bill it's a simple bill it
really is just giving workers freedom to
choose whether or not they believe a
labor union you know benefits them yeah
it's it's about personal
freedom just quick followup for a
followup please yeah I just I just don't
think that most people really understand
what this bill does and what it's trying
to do so I I kind of would have to
disagree with what here okay so we can
ask questions yeah so the question is do
you really believe that people
understand what this Bill is saying and
that it really affects them in any way
shape or form I I believe they
understand it and I believe that it does
affect look a you know Rising tide lifts
all boats you know if you got more jobs
coming into the state by definition
that's going to mean those are better
jobs because if people come in and offer
employment they're not going to get any
takers unless they're offering better
than what people already
have okay and representative farington
thank you Mr chairman we've heard a lot
about this legislation weakening unions
is is Union participation higher in
right to work states or non-right to
work
states it varies a good bit uh in
particular I I from memory Alabama and
uh Nevada have higher Union
participation rates uh Wisconsin I think
too uh than New Hampshire um I mean
overall by and large forced unionism
states have higher Union density but is
that correlation or
causation okay and representative
Granger thank you Mr chair why would
unions demand the right to represent
non-members uh they get a lot of power
by virtue of the fact that they they
have control over all the workers and
and there's no competition I mean if if
you had workers able to I mean like look
as a manager it's pretty easy to
negotiate pay for multiple people I mean
I manage a couple people and it's not a
big time suck for me um you know but but
really I I mean you know if you actually
started seeing workers paid better I
mean there was a case out in uh Nebraska
a good long time ago but uh School Board
couldn't find a teacher to teach shop
class uh for you know they had to offer
$5,000 more money because there simply
were no qualified people to actually
teach the thing um you know and the Nea
took them to court saying no you're
paying them more you know that's
unacceptable and the their lawyer uh
told the Omaha World Herald that that
was a victory for collective bargaining
when when that failed I mean that's one
of the very few cases that actually came
out but um you know there's this sort of
idea that you know yeah I mean it allows
them to present the fiction that like
everyone's benefiting because it's
everyone get the same deal that that
example okay so we can ask questions for
a long time and the longer we ask
questions the longer we go so if it is a
Germain question that is going to help
our understanding of HB 238 please ask a
question thank you Mr chair do you
consider it a hostage
scenario uh yeah no I mean they're not
Free Riders they're captive
passengers thank you okay seeing no
further questions sir thank you for your
testimony I'm sorry were you up
representative
kahill for your question thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr Cal I think you
mentioned Oklahoma as a right to work
state were they an early adopter or just
recent uh they were
2001 2001
yes interesting uh followup for a
followup yes well I I was reading that
in the 90s they were trying to attract
United Airlines and they sent they sent
people to live to go and visit Oklahoma
City for a week and the they came back
and they said they didn't want to live
there nothing against Oklahoma City
myself but it wasn't until they enacted
a 1% sales tax and started investing in
the in the in the town that they were
attracting businesses and in fact
they're going to have an Olympic event
some 2,000 miles away from the Summer
Olympics is should we enact a 1% sales
tax in New Hampshire do we draw relate
to HB 238 sir I vaguely I give you
exceptionally vely I see see yeah okay
all right and representative clerk yeah
thanks again Mr chair so do you
understand that the Union's wages are a
minimum wage for their
employees uh yeah I guess in a sense
yeah okay just a quick followup please
please
um as long as are you aware that as long
as they get the minimum their minimum
wage they can actually get
more so if I just as an example I'm a
union carpenter if I I make X I can
negotiate for more as you know by being
a
foreman producing more um and and a
company that I work for can give me
benefits and higher pay if they so
choose as long as I get at least the
minimum are you aware of that um so
there are a lot of weird things in the
construction industry uh that's that's
not typical of a lot of unionized
employment but yeah I me I mean
obviously if you move into a if you're a
teacher if you get your master's degree
but it's it's set by the terms of the
contract were you aware of that I could
do that though uh no there's as I said
there are a lot of weird things in the
construction
industry okay one last look around we're
clear thank you sir appreciate your
testimony I'd like to call Kristen bone
and before we get started the we are
going to go through lunch uh so we're
just going to continue driving through
uh members of the committee if you'd
like to take a break by all means take a
break we need to maintain a quorum of 11
and uh outside of that ma'am the floor
is yours great thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman and honorable committee members
my name is Kristen Gowan and I represent
the electrical contractors Association
representing um electrical construction
companies so that's the employers the
business owners both small and large
here in New Hampshire and our
jurisdiction also covers Massachusetts
and Maine um some of the ibw members
that are employed by my employers are um
residents of New Hampshire but maybe
members of other local unions um
throughout the region so I am here today
to testify in opposition to House Bill
238 um also known as right to work as I
mentioned NAA we our contractors are
responsible electrical and
telecommunication
contractors um and what we do is we
advance the industry through advocacy
education research and standards
development and we are only able to
accomplish this as an employer
organization in conjunction with our
partner ship with the ibw the
International Brotherhood of Electrical
Workers our partnership with the ibw
allows us to perform work with special
knowledge and experience needed for
every kind of project that you can
imagine it allows us to reduce accidents
and injuries and in turn reduce costly
delays on projects our partnership with
the ibw allows us to eliminate call
backs limit change orders helps to avoid
emergencies that can bust budgets on
these construction projects and
incidents that turn into legal issues
when a contractor calls the hiring Hall
at the
ibw they know that they're going to get
someone who is trained and
knowledgeable in short this partnership
guarantees that our contractors get a
job when we get a job it will be staffed
by the highly skilled workers who
complete this on time many times under
budget and that work is performed on
that job is the highest
quality the point of all this is we can
do do this because of the agreements
that we privately negotiate with the ibw
and its members both ibw members and the
contractors that I represent provide
value to one another the electricians
receive training Fair pay safe working
conditions and the contractors in turn
receive highly trained and skilled
workers that meet these requirements and
obligations on Project once again zero
cost to the general public this has been
our business model for de ades and we do
not need nor want government to
interfere with the contracts and the
agreements that we make as a private
Business Association this relationship
is essential not only to our continued
success but also to the continued
success of infrastructure projects
throughout this state and the
country although most of our ni
contractors are small business owners we
also have large multinational companies
as our members all of these businesses
that we represent think right to work is
bad for business so on behalf of all of
the large medium and small businesses
that we represent we respectfully
request that you vote against House Bill
238 thank you thank you for your
testimony right on time um you're
brilliant and brief good um any
questions from the
committee seeing no questions thank you
so much for your testimony appreciate it
and we have Mr Mike King please you want
to break for lunch first or we're not
breaking for lunch okay we're driving on
and
kellbell
okay uh I want to thank the committee
for their time and their efforts in its
matter it's very uh close to my heart I
appreciate it and I want to thank
everybody for the uh thorough questions
the gentleman down in the corner uh with
the gray suit sir the uh asking of the
vice president of the citizens against
uh citizens for right to against right
to
work okay like know it was good to know
that uh the businesses are paying his
salary sir Berlin I think you might uh
solve your problem by establishing a
major hospital and a major college up
that way if that's
possible okay um my name is Mike King
I'm a local 7 iron worker spent uh 22
years on the iron before I got
hurt
um I wrote something down here and I I
hope that uh you can all relate to it
okay uh if we're lucky and I do mean
lucky uh we all get 100 years to
live okay
there's a lot of moments in 100 years
okay every moment is
precious every moment is an opportunity
to invest in the next moment after
it okay
now the ideal life consists of 20 years
of learning what 45 years of earning and
the rest for yearning are your golden
years
okay uh just like we strive for that
pillow every night to get some rest
relaxation and hopefully some comfort we
do the same thing for our
retirements okay we all strive to reach
retirement with so we can rest relax and
be comfortable hopefully but you can't
be comfortable if you don't have any
money okay now
as a union member I received a pension
an annuity in
healthcare okay I retired with dignity I
never thought that
was excuse me I never thought that was
possible where I came
from uh but I did it and uh all thanks
to local 7 I'm an investor I made a lot
of good investments in my life 30 years
ago I quit drinking and smoking decided
mind then I joined local 7 252 25 years
ago I've been almost three years now
I've been
out great investment from that I
compounded a house but and paid for now
okay I have an annuity and I have a
pension okay I quadrupled my pension my
excuse me my nudity last year in the
stock market
so what I was able to do was generate
generational wealth if there's any
investors around here phenomenal okay
kid who grew up eating out of trash
barrels because he was so hungry being
caught by the cafeteria lady which was
very embarrassing sh please so this is a
compelling testimony okay yeah fair I
just want to let you people know what
the union has done for me so are you in
FA of right to work or not in favor I'm
no I'm against right to work okay thank
you that's what I thought thank you okay
all right I apologize okay are there any
questions for this witness no I'm not
sure am I done yes sir a I got I got
some good stuff I know I know you do and
and we would love to read that you can
put it on the portal or you can hand it
to us and it'll be available to all of
us I I didn't get to the good part yet
well may may can can we make an
amendment for that it can be alloted
yeah we're we're making an amendment if
are any questions
please representative stop um Mr King
what what is the best part of your
testimony that we did not hear oh thank
you I appreciate you okay uh when a
union member retires okay they have a
nice retirement package okay like I said
the anity of the pension is soal
security I refer to it as the plot of
gold everybody that's a union member
retires with dignity and a part little
part of gold now the nonunion
members the only one that retires with a
part of gold is the owner of the
company okay and so those people have to
suffer for the rest of their lives might
the goal in life okay is to not have
ever worry about a bill again isn't it
they never have to
work okay for your time to be of leisure
folks that's what a union does for
members okay right the work New
Hampshire as we all know we all read the
paper or the the computer New Hampshire
is the number one state in the country
to
retire okay Manchester New Hampshire is
the hottest uh real estate market in the
country Manchester New
Hampshire okay we did all that without
right to
work why do we need right to work thank
you okay any further
questions seeing no further questions
sir thank you for your testimony thank
please and on Deck is representative Kum
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Janice Kelby and
I'm a retired postal worker I worked a
midnight shift in a mail processing
plant at the USPS for over 29 years I
currently live in hooks at New Hampshire
I was a single parent when I was hired
and very aware that the benefits that
made me want to seek a job at the post
office had been obtained through the
union and their
negotiations it is more evident with the
Postal Service than it is a lot of
places because the postal service has a
category of employees called casuals
casuals weren't necessarily shortterm
some had worked for more than 10 years
they were not part of the bargaining
unit and the that made the difference
between what the Postal Service gave you
out of the kindness of their heart and
what had been attained by the union very
clear casuals wages were far less than
ours although they often did identical
work they got no sick leave no health
benefits earned minimal time off paid
time off and no retirement benefits
folks were not knocking down the doors
to become a casual they wanted the
career jobs they wanted them complete
with all the benefits negotiated by the
union so workers who are telling you
they want nothing to do with the Union
are not being 100% honest they do want
want the benefits that were achieved by
the union and the benefits do not just
simply fall out of the sky sadly working
for the USPS is somewhat like being in a
right to work state people who choose
not to join a union don't share the cost
of representation most postal workers
join a union but not all having some
people enjoy the contract benefits
without helping with the cost does in
fact create Division and resentment do
Union is obligated by federal law to
represent the non-members who pay
nothing not even for their own personal
representation I know in my local we um
had to defend a guy who was not a union
member and the fees for the arbitrator
for just one day and this was 20 years
ago was
$1,500 just for a one day hearing that
came out of my dues not his the bigger
issue is the considerable resources that
go in to negotiating a contract I went
to a national arbitration case to
testify one time about the job duties of
a particular job and I listened first to
The Economist talk and several other
expert Witnesses those people were paid
to be there by the union and that's what
made us get an increase in the wages for
that particular job that wouldn't happen
without that I just have one question if
there's
people thank you for your testimony
questions seeing no question I'm sorry
representative St or Schultz thank you
Mr chair um I would would love to hear
your question and I don't know it's of
us as a committee or my my question is
why if there are all these businesses
are going to flock to New Hampshire if
we get right to
work didn't anybody tell them that right
to work or that a agency fee is not a
requirement they don't have to negotiate
it so that's nothing but baloney that
they're going to flock here to New
Hampshire they could flock here now and
say no I don't want a fair share
Clause thank you ma'am are there any
seeing Don thank you so much I'd like to
call Representative C culum
please and on Deck is representative
representative
Howard thank you Mr chairman and hello
to my fellow labor committee members
sorry that I'm not with you this year uh
for the record I'm r representative r
kulum from Hillsboro District
30 heard from one of the previous uh
speakers that those people who work for
non-union companies um don't prosper
from it and that the only person who
walks away with the gold is the
owner I'd like to share my story uh I
started working for a commercial heating
and air conditioning company back in
1993 and my position was an entry-level
position over the course of my 25 years
there I retired as a vice president and
general manager running an operation of
with a six million actually more than $6
million
budget uh we were non-union and I
believe that I advocated pretty well for
myself and that the owner of the company
was not the only one who walked away
with the gold that many of us had the
opportunity to advance ourselves in that
company and advocate well for ourselves
and they worked with us to help reach
our
goals so one of the things I'd like to
share is over the 25 years that I was
there um when I started we had 125
employees over the 25 years we grewed
over 400
employees throughout the course of that
time we had the trade unions um coming
in they would send in their employees
and they tried multiple times to to
organize our our um company they were
tireless at it we were successful every
time and um we believe it was because we
offered great benefits great wages we
had a strong focus on safety we had
continual training
we had a robust health and dental
insurance plan which you hear to today
that that doesn't exist with non-union
companies so the you know as a non-union
company we also did a lot of government
work between the state and with the
federal agencies and we were required to
pay the prevailing rates which was the
union scale wages that we were hearing
about today and having been a person who
did the certified payroll I could see
that we almost always paid higher than
the Union scale Rate rates and we didn't
have the adjustments that we could take
off and deduct from those union scale
rates that the union had so they had an
advantage over us on the competition for
um winning these jobs bidding on these
jobs but we were still successful in
keeping ourselves in the
market so we hear about the policies
that don't create jobs um or improve
economic outcomes again I'll say that we
grew to over 400 employees so we created
I believe that had the union been
successful in organizing us that the
those employees um who wanted to remain
as non-union should have had that right
they started off with a company that was
non-union it was the Union sending in
their employees to try to organize us so
they should have had that right to stay
representing themselves they should have
had the right to not pay union
dues thank you representative appreciate
your
testimony uh any questions for
representative
kookum thank you representative we miss
you here too we we wish we're still on
the committee um and and we've talked
before and where you work sounds like a
great place and I would never ever knock
that and I would never knock any uh open
shop company that provides for their
employees like yours did just a quick
question though did did you have to
contribute for your like health
insurance or anything like that or was
that fully company funded
it's an interesting question um I did
have to
contribute and um my employees all of
the employees had to contribute I it was
a 8020 split the company picked up 80%
we paid 20 and I had a woman who was
working for me who didn't join who
didn't sign on for the benefits and what
she told me was her husband was a
carpenter um union carpenter worker and
he had to buy the insurance benefits and
he didn't have the option to opt out so
he was paying over $300 a week for his
insurance benefits that she could have
bought for $60 a week through our
organization can I can I follow up with
that for follow up Sir um just as so you
know we don't pay for our health
insurance our people that we work for
it's in the contract as part of our
contract that it the uh companies that
we work for pay for our health insurance
I should clarify this was this was in
New York so it may be different there I
I do not know I'm just saying in New
Hampshire nothing comes out of my check
for my health insurance the insurances
were equal as far as their coverage they
were very comparable yep good I'm again
I I happy for you that everything was
great and represent
stab thank you uh thank you for taking
my question it's good to see you um my
question is if your company had not been
so good to its employees do you think
the union might have had more success in
workplace hard to say I mean it's
possible Right but they knew they knew
we were treating our employees well and
what the benefits were for them it was
strictly a membership financial gain for
them to come in and get our employees
into their
Union okay um no further questions I'd
like to to uh bring representative Matt
Coker up and and uh representative
Howard will get you right after him
that's
okay and he was waiting right outside so
by okay so we'll catch him later uh
representative Howard it's on you thank
you sir I appreciate that
and uh on Deck is Kim
Hokinson thank you honorable Mr chair
and uh committee members my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington in
straford District 4 I'm the son of a
union member in the Rochester school
district and have seen how unions work
firsthand because they're not just
organizations but communities when I was
16 years old I broke my back and my mom
used all of her sick days and all of her
vacation days to be with me the thing is
is that fellow teachers and Union
members made us meals gave us gas cards
and even visited Us in the hospital the
union was there for my family when we
needed it most HB 238 is a bill that
would destroy the ability for labor
unions to organize and undermine the
very agreement of how they can function
effectively I want to give a little
background to the committee about the
formation and dissolution of labor
unions they are formed by holding an
election and can be dissolved by holding
an election just like this past November
when Donald Trump became president
presid of the United States or in 2020
when Joe Biden did we are all subject to
the same laws and taxes implemented by
them workplaces operate just like any
other state and whether you like paying
taxes or dues they fund important
infrastructure essential to benefiting
the masses I'll end my analogy Now by
making a stark contrast between the
government and unions unions are widely
trusted and unite people of all
political parties why because they
consistently produce results for workers
in the form of better contracts pay or
benefits passing this legislation would
create the opportunity for people to
freeload off of a union by benefiting
from everything that the dues pay for
without contributing it is an All or
Nothing Game and demand the same
benefits uh and and if an employer uh
were to deny uh sorry I apologize this
so-called white right to work
circumvents the whole election process
making it pointless and it turns in turn
tramples the right of others if people
want to stop working in a union
workplace they can vote on it simply put
right to work is wrong for New Hampshire
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh are there any questions of this
witness seeing no questions thank you
and do you have your written testimony
uh I can forward it to the committee if
you could put it that in representative
C if you have yours um that would be
fine
too okay thank you
ma'am and uh Kim
Hokinson thank you and on Deck is David
bio
Bobo
gotcha I have to look at the clock so I
can say good afternoon um good afternoon
my name is Kim Hokinson I am the deputy
director of contract relations for the
North Atlantic states Regional Council
of Carpenters I'm here as a nashaa
resident but also obviously representing
my
organization um and I'm here today to
read a letter that eight of our largest
New Hampshire companies uh drafted and
signed on to so we have John Ben Bennett
who's the president of New England
finish systems in Salem Hampshire Tom
Steves who's the president of TJ
McCartney in Nashwood New Hampshire uh
Dan Lynch who's a president of Lio
Construction Marco plant who's the VP of
saon wall in Hudson New Hampshire Ronda
paler who's the CEO of universal drywall
in Auburn Christine St laurant who is a
partner of genx Construction Group in
Hudson Dave anone who's a president of
Salem H excuse me president of AEG in
Salem New Hampshire and Tom Butler who
is a principal of Select tile in
Salem and this is their
letter as members of the New Hampshire
business community and signatory
contractors with the North Atlantic
states Regional Council of Carpenters we
are writing to express our strong
opposition to HB 238 FN so-called Right
to Work bill as you
know uh for almost 20 years and I think
it's as we've heard today much longer
than that uh years efforts to pass this
legislation have been defeated by bar
bipartisan groups of legislators who
voted down these bills because they knew
right to work is bad for New Hampshire
workers taxpayers and businesses as
business owners we believe that right to
work is bad public policy because it
mandates government interference in a
free market and will adversely impact
our New Hampshire based businesses if
passed by this legislation right to work
will intrude on our business's ability
to freely negotiate contracts that we
determine are in the best interest of
our companies this is not a decision
that State should be making especially
here in New Hampshire this legislation
will also adversely impact our
businesses because it harms the unions
Industries leading training programs
that provide our businesses with highly
trained
workers as building contractors we are
partners with the North Atlantic states
training fund which provid comprehensive
reliable skill training and professional
development of our Workforce at no cost
to the state
taxpayers the training fund Apprentice
model is also one of the most successful
recruiting and retention tools available
to our companies by weakening unions and
our training programs right to work will
make it harder for us to find trained
employees in New Hampshire that will
economy we also believe that passing
right to work will harm our communities
because studies are shown oh I'm the
slow reader you all have it in front of
you but please uh it's okay ma'am you
you passed it out and so we have that in
the record yeah thank you very much are
there any questions for this witness
representative
stub thank you um thank you for taking
my question um I live in Manchester and
I often go by the beautiful facility
that the Carpenters um Training Center
is and I am just um wondering you said
that that that this um Right to Work
would impact the ability to train
Carpenters um how many do you know how
many people or how many trainees there
are are or could you get that
information to us of how many Carpenters
are being trained that's a great
question we actually have our lead
instructor from the training center here
today to testify as well so I believe
we'll make sure that Mark is able to
answer that question for you but it is a
like you said we have an amazing
training facility right on Candy Road
here in man well not here sorry down in
Manchester and it it is amazing to be
able to have New Hampshire residents
train for free at no cost just like the
gentleman's uh Grand granddaughter
behind us right she was able to train
for free to like you know I started 19
years ago myself right 13 years in the
field working it is an amazing
opportunity to get a free
education so thank you for bringing that
up thank you yeah other
questions all right thank you ma'am we
appreciate your
testimony and David bobo please is next
and on Deck we have um
step
Stefan genso
genow we good okay thank you appreciate
your patience sir hi thank you for uh
taking the time to hear me out uh I just
want to say I'm kind of G to wing it a
little bit I had something written up
but after hearing all the testimony I
kind of see that a lot of you really
understand more so what this bill is
about than the previous year when I was
here um which which is good to see um
I'm representing Gen X Construction
and save on wall construction here I'm a
project manager for them we do anywhere
from 50 to $75 million worth of
construction work a year um we oppose
this we think that it's not good for New
Hampshire um we are I heard somebody
mention something about it being
compared to a hostage hostage situation
as far as being a union member me myself
I am a union member as well um I'm
actually a union member who was just
diagnosed with cancer in the past two
months and because I'm a union member
the one thing I didn't have to worry
about throughout all this is how I was
going to P to pay for it my family's
taken care of my medical is covered all
I've got to do is focus on getting
better and I can do that because the
union helps me I work non-union for 20
years in this industry I didn't have
anything that I have like I do now
because of the
Union I don't have to pay my dues
I have the right to go work anywhere I
want I do it by choice every member does
it by choice no one's forced to do
anything um I think that's the part that
really people don't understand with this
no one's forced to do
this um and the fact that it keeps
coming up and we got to keep talking
about it even though it get shot down
repeatedly I understand that that's how
legislation Works um I think there's
better things our tax dollars can be
going for then talking about this
situation consistently that keeps
getting shot
down um the education's great as an from
an employer standpoint the people that
we get from the Carpenters Union they're
educated they're safe they're not going
to hurt themselves when they go to work
we're confident in that we don't have to
worry about having to call someone's
family and say Hey Joe fell off the
staging he's not going to be home
tonight Joe was trained how to walk on
that staging to make sure that he's
going to be safe and get home to his
family you don't really get that
anywhere else without having to pay out
of pocket the Carpenters Union does that
for us so for the measly 20 something
dollars we pay in dues a month my return
on investment is tfold do it I do it
gladly every time that's really all I
have to say I appreciate your testimony
questions seeing no questions thank you
thank you sir appreciate it and on Deck
we have Mark
andion atarian Mark ataran good
afternoon Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Stephan consalvas
I'm here for myself my family and my
union I've uh worked for the United
Steel Workers and lived in Salem New
Hampshire for over 20 25 years I raised
three children two of which are adult
now in New Hampshire um my middle my
middle daughter when she was three years
old was diagnosed with
histiocytosis it's it's a disease that
basically it ate her ate her bones in
her ear um in
over probably 20 surgeries
chemotherapy uh now years later it's
considered a cancer but because of my
union in my Union Insurance
and everything that my union did for me
I didn't pay one cent out of my pocket
for the hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars of medical bills
that we had um my question is why and
when why do we continue to try to pass
this so-called right to work in a state
where we don't want it or need it when
is this going to stop I have been here
for every every time this is come up in
the last 20 something
years we will never stop fighting this
because it is wrong for New
Hampshire we have Janice we have other
workers ability not to join Union so why
our private businesses don't want it
this is not nor do our workers so why
influences from other states come here
handing out donations and the promise of
something that just isn't
true our state is growing for the better
and we don't need any so-called help
from right to work do we want to grow or
do we want to go backwards because the
truth is right to work states although I
heard how happy they are I don't know
how you're happy being
poorer worse medical and worse schools
than anywhere else in the country so
what I want to leave for my children is
not that please vote no on HB 238 the
Hampshire is better than
this thank you sir appreciate your
testimony do we have any
questions seeing no questions thank you
you Mark
anaran atarian thank you
Deck good morning good morning Mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Mark atarian I'm the lead
instructor at the North Atlantic states
cage training Fund in Manchester New
Hampshire my wife and I live in New
Hampshire for the my wife and I have
lived in New Hampshire for the last 22
years and we have two adult children who
work and live in our great
state I'm here today because I believe
that our citizens deserve to know the
truth about HB 238 FN
the right to work in the phrase right to
work itself is intended to deceive and
confuse working Americans about the
impact such laws will have on their
working
conditions as Martin Luther King Jr
pointed out in
1961 right to work is a false
slogan since right to work laws provide
neither rights nor work and in fact are
designed to Rob us of our civil rights
and job rights
right to work is also design designed to
destroy labor unions and the freedom of
collective bargaining by which the
unions have improved wages working
conditions for
everyone decades later research proves
King's contention that wherever these
laws have been passed wages are
lower no New England state has a right
to work law and repeated
defeats repeated defeats to fight uh
work bills have demonstrated its
persistent unpopularity among the
Hampshire rers and with legisl from both
parties the north atlan States cist
training fund invests more than $13
million in our apprentiship and
journeyman training programs across our
region at on the Hampshire Training
Center we provide comprehensive reliable
skill training and professional
development for our State Workforce at
no cost to the
taxpayers these training programs
provide more than our more than 100 New
Hampshire based Union contractors with
highly skilled safe and reliable
Workforce that allows them to be
successful in a competitive construction
industry the passage of right to work
law would negatively impact our apprenti
program by potentially weakening the
bargaining powers of
unions which plays a significant role in
managing and promoting apprenticeship
programs potentially leading to fewer
apprenticeship opportunities lower
quality training
standards and less stability and
opportunity for our apprentices to do uh
to reduce Union
protections unions particularly the
building trade unions actively negotiate
for apprenticeship programs with
collective bargaining agreements
ensuring quality standards and
commitment from employers to train
apprentices in the workforce of
tomorrow with right to work laws where
workers are not required to contribute
to the cost of their
representation this leverage would be
diminished thank you sir I appreciate
your testimony very well done thank you
any questions representative lar excuse
me yeah thanks Mr raran appreciate your
your testimony today that building that
um representative stub alluded to
earlier how
much State funding Federal funding
whatever went into that building
zero and who who contributed
to every C Union paid for it for a
followup sir I'm sorry I'm sorry Mr
Speaker absolutely Mr chair uh followup
if I may absolutely I apologize um
so who actually paid for that building
we did the copy this Union yeah thank
you sorry about that Mr chair no worries
representative
stop thank you Mr chair um um my
question earlier was how many uh
students do you have currently um
working in that building um you also
have apprentices but how big is the
program well the program is is quite big
um on any on any given week we have 25
to 30 students uh being trained in our
facility uh in various aspects of what
we do as far as commercial work it could
be finished work it could be doors and
hardware um and every week it changes
but on an average 25 to 30 apprentices a
week we
train followup and and that's yes ma'am
you may have a followup thank you and
that's that's a rotating so people who
are in the apprenticeship program um get
trained and then they're working out in
the field with a with a master Carpenter
correct yeah correct so they they come
to school once every three months um and
whatever their schedule is at for a
second third year fourth apprentices uh
wherever their skill level is is kind of
where their classes follow up would you
say just one more would you say
ma'am yes you may have a followup it's a
question that requires an answer okay
once the answer is provided then you may
proceed okay thank you yes ma'am um
would you say there are hundreds of
people being trained oh certainly not I
mean this we're just one Training Center
there's there's potentially thousands
every week being trained okay thank you
um one more followup stand by
representative grer you had a question
uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
for taking my question do you have any
data that shows that when a state passes
right to work that wages go down in that
state I I do not personally know
thank you for taking my question you're
welcome you're welcome and represent
stop thank you um is there any other
place for people to get this kind of
training not that I know of okay
community
colleges I don't I don't believe so all
right I don't believe there's any
program like ours all right thank you
okay thank you so much are there any
other
questions seeing n thank you sir
appreciate your work and your testimony
thank you
I'd like to call uh Dr Kenny
Friedman and thank you ma'am honorable
chairman and members of the committee
thank you for your patience and for
listening and being here my name is Gail
Kenny I reside in Kanan New Hampshire
I'm a pastor with the Meridan
Congregational Church and I also speak
on behalf of the economic Justice
Ministry of the New Hampshire United
Church of Christ which is the largest
Protestant denomination of the state and
I'm also here on behalf of other clergy
as well so numerous New Hampshire Faith
leaders from multiple Traditions
Catholic Protestant Jewish and others
have been vigorous in their opposition
to to deceptively labeled um a right to
work work bills in New Hampshire
whenever they have been introduced Faith
leaders have been here saying no this is
not right for New Hampshire and I
believe that the Catholic dasis of New
Hampshire has already submitted their
own very strong testimony opposing on HB
238 so our multiple Faith Traditions
lead us to understand that workers
deserve to have a voice on the job and
the right to come together collectively
we also believe that New Hampshire
employers have the right to NE negotiate
with their workers without the heavy
hand of the legislature interfering with
this very specific their contractual
provisions and this bill is nothing more
than that heavy hand so whether you're
religious or not uh you've probably
heard of The Ten Commandments including
commandment number nine which is Thou
shalt not bear false witness so
unfortunately um New Hampshire
legislators have been cons have
consistently received false witness
about um so-called Right to Work bills
and I'd like to correct just some of the
record um the truth is that no matter
what is claimed by the Bill's proponents
the historic Origins and purposes of
this bill are to divide workers and
Union strength and Effectiveness
the truth is that for decades Right to
Work proponents have made wildly false
claims about employers just waiting at
New Hampshire's borders to set up shop
in our state of only the spill is passed
but no one no one has ever been able to
identify a single business that falls
into this category of waiting at our
borders and the reason is because they
do not exist they didn't exist in West
Virginia either and the governor said so
uh the truth is that um New Hampshire
employers with unionized employees and
you've just heard this from several
employers and employer groups are not
asking for this bill um this bill is
focused on employers with unions so you
can take all the testimony you want from
business group that represent primarily
non-unions employers but this is about
telling employers with unions what they
can and can't do in their own contracts
and I will say that that um they are not
asking you to do this no employer has
come to you and said employer with a
union has come to you and said help me
for myself I don't know what's best for
me so do something for me by making a
certain contract clause illegal um the
other thing is this just very very
quickly um this Bill the national Right
to Work committee has not told where
apprciate your testimony and your
passion comments do we have you read my
testimony about where this bill really
came from yes ma'am thank you do you
have any
questions okay thank you so much
appreciate your
time and Aubrey Friedman please and on
paof Committee Member MERS Aubrey fre um
excuse me Mr chairman committee members
Aubrey Friedman I live in Bridgewater I
speak in support of this bill um the
main thing is that all workers are not
the same they're individuals we have
some workers that are more skilled some
are smarter and frankly some work harder
than others why should there be a
collective bargaining agreement that
treats everybody the
same individual members who work for the
company should be able to negotiate
directly that's the Crux of the issue
here it's the collective bargaining that
makes everyone be part of the collective
I have uh my son is actually in a union
I I never joined a union I just didn't
need to and I was able to and I'm not a
fantastic negotiator I was always able
to get the wages or conditions benefits
whatever it was that satisfied me and I
didn't want a third party to represent
me and I think there are other people
who feel the same way too I'm not
opposed to the unions but forcing
everybody to become part of it and uh
and then this business about the uh
benefits and I've heard people bring it
up several times and they say Well
they're getting the benefits but they're
not paying if you negotiate separately
for yourself with your employer which
you should be free to
do then why do they have to offer you
you can't get the same bet so somebody
said well they went to a hearing for no
you don't get the goodies if you're not
willing to pay and that's just part of
choosing not to join a union they should
be free to do that maybe they'll do
better maybe they'll do worse I don't
know depends up however they do it
you're you're an individual you've got a
mind you can speak for yourself if it
doesn't work out you'll go somewhere
else so I think think that's the Crux of
the issue the problem is the collective
if let's say 90% of the people want to
join let them have their own Union their
benefit 10% don't they don't get the
goodies let them be separate employers
handle all kinds of different uh
negotiations all the time and it's not
like everybody is just set the way it is
I mean that's how many private
Industries work they just they have
different benefits it's all different it
doesn't have to be one size fits all so
I think that's the problem the
collective part of it if it were allowed
to be separate uh where you could
negotiate your
own uh whatever you wanted for your
wages and conditions and benefits then
let it be if the 90% let them have their
own thing why Force the other 10% or
whoever it might be I still think most
people would probably choose the union
but for those who don't leave them alone
let's don't be a busy body you worry
about that's it thank you thank you
thank you sir I appreciate your
questions see representative Flanigan
for you sir thank you Mr chairman I was
going to bring this up during um our
executive but I wanted to share it with
this this testimony are you sharing are
you asking I'm sharing okay let's ask I
will put in a form of a question put it
in a form of question please thank you
do thank you for testifying did you know
since the Janice decision that the
public sector has lost over a million
union
members uh but aren't people still
contributing I mean the unions still
seem to be pretty active from what I've
seen that's the numbers that I'm hearing
or reading is that a million people
don't want to okay so this is a question
and we can bring it up in executive okay
thank thank you okay thank you seeing no
more questions thank you sir for your
testimony thank you and representative
polos off thank you on deck we have
Sarah Kelly please Mr chair let's uh
think about the children for the record
my name is y po representing mar mar
hookit and Dan Barton uh I testify in
support of this bill and yet another
reason to support it because it will
help help New Hampshire children Harvard
University uh they published uh research
called the longrun effects of right to
work laws you can find it on their
website and Benjamin Austin and Matthew
Lily they uh studied years upon years of
data comparing to V States and states
that don't have this legislation and one
of the Central findings was that right
to work laws are associated with lower
childhood
poverty and uh uh actually children from
poor
families uh in uh uh if they are growing
up in a right to walk
location uh they have
1.7 percentage Point higher probability
of succeeding fin finally in their life
so it's a greater upward Mobility it's a
chance for kids from poor family to
become
financially um substantial and um uh uh
it's uh proven uh scientifically this
difference in outcomes were not present
prior to the passage of right to work
laws they persist after controlling for
other major policy differences between
states
uh and uh they do not appear primarily
attributable to local substitutions so
please help New Hampshire children
succeed thank you for considering and
supporting this law uh I will not be
taking questions but I have my notes for
secretary thank you thank you I
appreciate the time and thank you for
handing the notes
and Joe Gallagher uh is on Deck uh thank
you sir thank you everyone thank you
ma'am good afternoon as I am 5'2 I have
no choice but to keep this short I am a
veteran who proudly served eight years
in the United States Marine Corps I
would still be serving today if I hadn't
literally worn myself to the Bone if my
Marines and I protested for higher pay
and better working conditions we would
have been charged with Mutiny this is
all to say I understand and appreciate
the power that the voices of the
American workers possess especially when
echoed in unison and that they should be
protected I stand Here on broken ankles
to oppose HB 238 for the repercussions
it poses and the false promises it makes
to every hardworking citizen of New
Hampshire the Right to Work bill
promises extra money in the individual's
pocket and the freedom to choose where
to work as a woman Living in America I
understand the sanctity and the ability
to shoes but the language issued in this
bill and promotional material for it are
intentionally misleading what this bill
will actually accomplish is division
amongst workers making them weaker in
their Singularity and the
Union's ability to provide competitive
wages vital employer-based health
coverage protection against
discrimination amongst countless other
benefits according to this bill the
freedom from Union fees is intended to
promote individuals applying to and
working for Industries in New Hampshire
this is a farce and a distraction from
the true barriers to employment that
American workers are facing unlivable
minimum wage lack of affordable housing
health care and child care as well as
unchecked predatory business practices
such as ghost ghost job postings
intentional understaffing and decreasing
full-time positions to undercut the
workforce all of this while corporate
profit is at an all-time high along with
the prices for essential Goods food and
gas if we want to strengthen the working
class we must address these issues
through a holistic approach that handles
each aspect as a portion of the problem
and not as individual issues we must
come together as a community and work
towards a resolution that allows all
workers the ability to achieve gainful
employment the answer is not in division
and Singularity it is in Union we are
stronger together thank you for your
time thank you Mar I appreciate your
questions
please if I understood your testimony
you were a marine that is correct sir
well thank you for that for the service
I appreciate your support you've heard a
lot about defending Freedom here uh in
terms of the way this is being
characterize this particular Bill yes
sir now you fought for freedom for a
long time yes sir so what is your
opinion of this legislation as it
relates to freedom and and do you see
this as is interfering with your freedom
it's not interfering with my personal
freedom but in my opinion the worker is
still free to choose not to work for a
union if they don't want a union job
don't apply for a union job to me it's
that
simple representative
Granger do do you think most workers
want to be in a union or do you think
that the revealed preferences is that
they don't want to be in a
union I believe that those who are
educated about what a union can provide
would choose to work with a union thank
you representative
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your service thank you for your
support um are you currently a member of
a union I am not
no do you work at a place that is
unionized or not unionized no sir okay
okay and thank no that's it thank you
okay thank you for com
out no further questions thank you ma'am
testimony and uh excuse me if we could
have Joe Gallagher please thank you pres
boder thank you Mr chair thank you to
all the committee members um my name is
Joe Gallagher I in Manchester I'm a
retired member of local six heat and
frost insulators and Allied Workers
again right to work does make your
constituents lose in the long run I'm
not paid to be here but I wish to give
some examples of the detrimental cost
from right to work our local Works in
New Hampshire Maine Mass R Island and
partially in Vermont and
Connecticut and when work is slow we can
go to other areas of the country and
work because they have similar type
unions to us and a lot of our guys used
to go down to Florida to work which is a
big right to work state now and they
could work
in the Jacksonville local the Tampa
local the Miami
local
now those locals are in
receivership okay those workers are up
here working for us because we're fairly
busy and they're working at a good
living
wage but they tell us what their wage is
down there and it's less than half of
what our wage is here and the benefits
are all degraded so I've seen this over
the years I'm been around 50 years in
the business so that's going to be a
cost to your
constituents next
uh you know the Merit shops will get
less than that so if they're getting
less than 50% of us the Merit shops are
even going under that so when it came
here say my peace many times in the past
I always noticed the same thing and it's
a little different today you got a lot
of people fall right to work but most of
the time as it's always been like six
for and 150 against so you know it's
Groundhog Day all over again I said it
before at these
meetings okay the last two times this
bill came up and if it passed and I was
here both times it would have a little
economic effect on those New Hampshire
because we've been going to the Fisher
Cats game since day one Mark McKenzie
would remember Union night and we have
never stopped but my local said to me
which is headquartered in Boston said
listen if your state passes right to
work you're going to the woo socks
so four years ago I remember the
gentleman that ran the uh Fisher Cats he
talked to the labor chair um who's the
that rep from uh the insurance rep
invent time yeah will he he called will
he was upset you know he says I'm going
to lose clients so my point is real
simple it's all about money here
and let me see I did send this to you
email and if you want me to resend it in
case of it went to spam that's fine so
like I said the woo we also do Canopy
Lake we have all the families do a
picnic that's on the table too you know
it's not me making that decision I've
been retired 11 years if and think of
all these people that live out of state
that are in Union say half a million in
Massachusetts they come up here on
vacation because I can talk I talk to
guys that do this all the time they say
what's going on in New Hampshire
especially with all those ads during the
um election because we all work
together all right I see my time is up
and any questions sir I appreciate your
experience and your testimony thank you
any
questions represent m
sir uh if I can call you Joe you can
been friends for a long time we've been
friends for a long time uh you've been
in the union 50 years yes uh as I have
in the 50 years that you've been there
did any of the members uh exercise their
right uh under the under the law to
desertify your union no no and uh half
our local came in from nonunion know to
the best of my knowledge because it
would be kept private uh has ever done
that so they have the right to petition
to or a followup please thank you no
question well the question was I just
want to uh get an agreement from him
relative to the ability of union workers
to decertify their Union can you phrase
that in a in a question are you familiar
with with the ability of the unions to
uh to
desertify certify okay thank you thank
you kind of
all right see you no questions SC and we
do support Berlin my wife's from that
neighborhood um Mckay boder boder please
and then uh on Deck is Deborah
house C Flor is yours thank you Mr
chairman and members of the
committee my name is McCain beter I am
the executive director of New England
citizens for right to work here to speak
in support of House Bill 238 in the
freedom of Association that it
advances right to work is a long overdue
reform already law of the land in Most
states which would simply protect
workers from being compelled to pay
union dues or fees without their consent
in order to work for a living
unfortunately under current law in New
Hampshire a union boson claim Monopoly
bargaining power over dissenting workers
taking away the individual's right to
negotiate for thems the union boss then
demands the government enforced
authority to extract mandatory dues or
fees from that unwilling worker adding
insult to injury this poll showed the
vast majority of Voters agree it's just
plain wrong bill would guarantee workers
the right to decide for themselves
whether or not labor union deserves
their financial support same as any
other private
organization once when asked if he would
support a controversial resolution at
ational Union con mention former Iowa
State Education Association executive
director Fred comr said hell no we don't
support it Iowa is a right to work state
we have to earn our membership if we
support that we lose too many members
you see without Right to Work
protections there's little incentive for
Union officials to offer a good service
they can compel people to pay them
either way fact is good unions don't
need forc dues bad unions don't deserve
them it's clear right to work would
benefit New Hampshire's economic Outlook
2013 to 2023 number of people employed
grew 5.5% in New Hampshire and only 0.3%
in forc unism States overall right to
work states on the other hand saw
16.0% roughly triple hours it's no
surprise because like countless
inquiries have shown a recent example
was last year's area development
magazines survey of Business Leaders and
site selection Consultants showed 78%
consider Right to Work stats either
important or very important in
determining where to build expand or
relocate
operations furthermore mer data reveals
residents of right to work states enjoy
roughly
$2,900 more in cost of living adjusted
after tax income per person per year
increase of over $10,000 in annual
purchasing power for a family of four
using the metric that actually matters
to Folks at kitchen tables therefore on
behalf of thousands of New England
citizens for Right to Work across the
state I urge the committee to support
House Bill 238 thank you thank you sir
appreciate your testimony do we have any
questions representative McKenzie thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your appearance for this committee uh
I'm going to read you a a a statement
and I'm going to ask you to uh let us
know if this is correct this statement
comes directly from the National Labor
Relations Board and it says the
following employees may choose not to to
become union members and pay dues are
opt out uh to pay dues their share of
the dues so it says the National Labor
Relations Board is saying that people
are not compelled to be union members
and they're not compelled to be in the
union do you agree with that statement
or disagree with the statement that
comes directly from the National Labor
Relations
material workers can be forced to pay
union bosses that's not the question
independent of their membership on the
roles those workers are forced to join
the union in a way every bit as sincere
as if they were on the roles they are
still compelled to associate with that
Union they're forced to fund that Union
that they may disagree with and they get
the short end of the stick and that they
lose the ability to try and change the
business agent representing them so
they are still forced to join Union in
the broad sense of the word in the true
sense of the word Mr chairman I have a
follow-up question for a
followup I'm GNA I'm going to ask you
again if I could
respectfully do you agree with the
statement that comes to the National
Labor Relations Board that says
employees may not uh may choose not to
dues Webster's Dictionary defines join
as quote to associate oneself with end
quote and certainly any worker compelled
to provide material support for an
organization is inherently compelled to
associate with it Force unionism
violates individual workers freedom of
Association whether or not the union
lists him on his official membership
roles or let them vote on internal
affairs and as was alluded to in earlier
testimony we can consider carefully a
quote from Article 2 Section one of the
UAW New National contract quote
employees covered by this agreement at
the time it becomes effective and who
are members of the Union at that time
shall be required as a condition of
continued employment to continue
membership in the union for the duration
of this agreement employees covered by
this agreement who are not members at
the time this agreement becomes
effective shall be required as a
condition of continued employment to
become members of the Union end quote
perhaps the UAW is being frank here and
the practices fall short of what is
permissible under current law or perhaps
the UW is simply trying to mislead
workers strong arming them into
submission either way right to work law
would help Shield Granite Staters from
such
Injustice okay thank you representative
Granger thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I've asked this
to other people perhaps you don't have
the data because previous people I've
asked did not have the data uh do you
have any data that shows whether or not
States when they pass a Right to Work
bill whether that puts wages up or down
yes I actually so I alluded to that in
my testimony where the cost of living
adjusted disposable income does go up
that
is typically secondary to job creation
uh Market forces tend to dictate salary
and as you have more companies moving
into a state and creating more jobs
there's more competition for workers so
that will naturally drive up uh wages I
can definitely
send the committee some specific studies
or I can dig through and pull some out
but they're academic research papers
that might not be the most brief or
compelling testimony on a
timeline yeah please submit those four
committee consideration yes sir and let
me get um representative McKenzie uh
thank you Mr chairman uh very quickly uh
I've heard the uh the language that you
have uh entered into the testimony here
relative to the UAW contract the last
time we had the right to work hearing I
asked either you or the another
representative to produce that uh
information I actually called the UAW uh
I can't find that language if you could
produce that language to the committee
that would be good because it would
suggest that they are they are in
violation of the law so if you could
produce that for the committee we would
appreciate it thank you Mr chairman
thank you
okay uh representative Sullivan
sir thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um you referenced U
increases in uh Economic Development
businesses moving into uh a new right to
work state can you
name several businesses that are on the
border dying to come in if we pass right
to
work that is a tricky question in part
because any business will to go on the
record saying such a thing is vulnerable
to unfair Labor practice prosecution
under the National Labor Relations Board
uh especially as appointed by Biden
we've seen that with a lot of the auto
manufacturers who have explicitly talked
about expanding in the right to work
South as opposed to States like
Washington or Oregon and then got
whacked for it uh one example of a
company that was willing to go on the
record was from Ruger here in New
Hampshire uh I've
got plenty of additional job creation uh
information I would be thrilled to
submit to the record as well and I'd be
happy to read through it at length if
committee I would agree thank you okay
thank you uh if you could submit that
through the portal and to the clerk I'd
stab yes um I received this on my porch
um and there's some information on here
and I'm just wondering if you can um
tell us where this this data came from
it says that um uh families and right to
work states earn on average
$4,200 in real household
income I guess that means more um um
Economic Policy Institute on the other
hand says in non-right to work states um
people receive three 3,940
more um and also there's some data here
about um right to work states having
nearly three times more job growth in
New Hampshire in the last decade can you
tell me where this information came
from sure so the first is National
Institute of Labor Relations research
they are using mer data that's Missouri
economic resource information and I'm
probably losing the last few words there
uh based on the Bureau of economic
research I can also submit that to the
committee uh the job creation itself is
similarly uh National Institute of Labor
Relations research and should be in that
same Source
length Okay please submit that data any
further questions representative Susi
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question so I'm fortunate
enough to be able to travel the South
through South Carolina and vacation
during the summer um with my family and
as I'm traveling down there I sometimes
I take the corridor of 95 and I see that
on the corridor of 95 for about four
miles there are many companies that
manufactur
vehicles I looked up to see why they
would go there energy costs are lower
easier for them to transport taxes a
lower so my question to you is in the
state of New Hampshire right now where
we have some of the highest taxes in
real estate we have a housing crisis it
a uh energy costs are ABS uh
astronomical and it's not really easy to
transport um their items through the
state of New Hampshire I guess I'm
curious as to how you feel that these
companies would prefer to come to New
Hampshire rather than going to a state
like South Carolina North Carolina these
companies that are waiting to come in
here well fortunately we don't have to
rely on my speculation uh there are
plenty of sources where people actually
go out and ask these exact job creators
I mentioned area development magazines
surveys the gentleman from the national
Federation of Independent businesses
mentioned their surveys I would be again
thrilled to read at length additional
surveys of of such job creators um but I
would be basing that claim off what
representative I'm sorry go
ahead thank you Mr chair so question on
the Janice decision I've heard that said
several times how do you think that
changes uh what we're looking at here on
the current bill uh and what it does
yeah thank you for the question so the
Janice
decision essentially brings Right to
Work protections to the public sector
Nationwide so
that for the time being solves the
problem for many public sector workers
in New Hampshire the same problem
remains for private sector workers so
we're seeking to expand those freedoms
that the Supreme
Court protecting the Janice decision to
the private sector uh there's also
always the risk with judicial precedent
that it could be overturned
uh we saw that the Janice decision
itself overturned previous president um
roie Wade is a prominent example
recently and so passing New Hampshire
right to work law would enshrine those
right to work protections for New
Hampshire workers in the public sector
even if the Supreme Court were to issue
a contradictory opinion down the
line thank you represent resident cing
all right are there any questions
representive L cler St uh for
question okay thank you and
representative L clerk thank you Mr
chair um
earlier I you heard my conversation with
Mr Helm and and um and I I would agree
that at least 80% of New England
citizens and the granted State citizens
believe that everybody has the right to
work but my question to him and to you
will be of those 80% how many do you
think understand what this bill really
is and and and you know I I I understand
your description and my description they
probably going to be two different
things but if they understood that this
was probably a union busting bill would
they
even would they even have an opinion
sure so different polls will phrase the
question different ways I'm not aware of
any polls that will just say do you
support right to work without giving any
context it's actually more common that
they will instead of using the phrase
Right to Work explain the logistics of
the bill um I mean at the national level
we've got survey USA or Gallop holes
that would certainly include New
things when Americans are asked if they
agree that workers should should never
be forced to join or pay a union uh this
Gallop poll is Right to Work
directly see the
question some states have passed Right
to Work of open shop laws that say each
worker has the right to hold job in a
company regardless his association with
the labor union if you asked to vote on
such a law would you have for it or
against it uh this is a WMUR Granite
State
man they don't have the specific
phrasing on here but it says they given
the basic premise behind the law and
that is typical for these so they will
uh yeah they will explain the bill not
just throw out the shorthand reference
to it uh as part of the polling process
may I please for for a quick please yes
thank you um and the way those questions
were phrased I would probably say yeah I
agree that not every company should be a
union
company but again would if if a person
knows that you know I'm just trying
to that this bill is
really to uh kind of eradicate the
unions you think it's someone would if
you ask the person hey do you wish there
were no more unions around do you think
yeah I think perhaps you're mistaken
about the language of the bill and would
invite you to reread the
legislation that how about answer my
question all right um last question go
ahead representative farington does this
bill in any way prevent somebody from
joining a labor union no it does
not okay any other
questions thank you m thank you
appreciate your testimony
thank
you and I'd like to call Deborah how
please and then uh on Deck uh Professor
dmouth
okay good afternoon chairman kraton and
members of the labor committee it is my
privilege to be here today testify can
you hear me okay I'll lean in a little
closer uh my name is Deborah H I am
president of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire we are a state
Federation of local labor unions mostly
in prek through 12 Public Schools we
also have City and town employees we
have a University faculty including one
private university which makes this um
proposed legislation relevant to us we
also are standing in solidarity with our
private sector Union brothers and
sisters we oppose HB 238 the Right to
Work bill and I will be very brief here
um this is interference in negotiations
between private sector employers and
private sector unions a workplace does
not become unionized unless the workers
vote to do so so already you know that
is a majority of workers have to vote to
become
unionized then you have negotiations
over the contract not every workplace
has an agency fee or fair share fee
whatever you call it that is not the
same as paying union dues union dues
gives you membership and aay in how the
union is run agency Fe agency fee all
the covers the cost of negotiating the
contract and enforcing or maintaining
the contract so that its terms apply
fairly to all the members of the
workforce having a law that says you
cannot negotiate that fee even if the
employer wants it and the union wants it
is government interference that's not
how we work in New Hampshire we think
the private sector should be able to be
the private sector and the government
should government should not be telling
it what to
do so that's the you know that's really
the Crux of what I have to say that's
not how we work in New Hampshire we have
a long tradition of rejecting this kind
of interference in private employment
it's it's a long tradition of standing
up for common sense and I've heard it as
a worker Liberty uh frame you don't have
the Liberty to go to your accountant and
say well you've done my taxes and you've
provided me a service but now I want the
liberty of not to pay for it you also
don't have the liberty of saying to the
union that has been elected by the other
workers in your workplace and saying you
know yeah you negotiated a contract for
me you are also taking on the cost of of
maintaining it which the employer has
agreed you have the right to charge for
but now I don't want to pay for it
that's called theft of services we urge
you to find HB 238 in expedience to
legislate it's not a freedom
issue a paying for services issue I do
have copies of my testimony to pass
around and I'm going to pass on
questions because I really don't have
anything new to say that hasn't already
been said okay thank you ma'am and we be
glad to read your testimony yeah thank
um Professor Dixon Professor Dixon
couldn't be here today can I read his um
Tony and who are you I'm April Richard I
also would like to submitted testimony
so if it's a conflict for me to be up
here twice yeah why don't you um submit
his in writing okay I do have copies for
everyone okay please and then uh did you
fill out a card already I'm sorry what
did you fill out a card okay so when
your card comes up you can testify and
then we'll read uh Professor
Dixon's uh as it's handed out okay thank
you
and uh and you are uh April Richard yes
yeah go ahead come on
please and then uh Matt uh Gavin glavin
is on
Deck good morning my name is April
richer I am a DOA resident I'm also a
city counselor in Dober New Hampshire
and I am a fellow with the American
friends service committee however I'm
not here today to speak um on behalf of
the those organizations I'm here to
speak as a 16-year Teamster employed
with
UPS I uh work the pre-dawn shift at UPS
loading the big brown package cars that
come to your homes and businesses when I
began work at UPS I remember asking
myself what kind of life is this the
founder uh Jim Casey fam famously is
quoted as saying one measure of success
will be the degree to which you build up
others who you work with he um
actually asked for his employees to be
unionized uh for the purpose of uh he
couldn't grow his business and
successfully provide for his
employees people often confuse the word
Union as an entity all to itself however
I am the union we are the union the
union is not somebody or something it is
an organization of workers form for the
purpose of advancing its members
interest in respect to wages benefits
and working conditions
to directly address comments um from
previous uh speakers employees should
determine their own Futures and I want
to find people who value their Union to
be in a union let me give you an example
of this in may have 2020 many of the
senior uh senior that's a term meaning
we've been employed for a long time UPS
employees were still angry over our
contract of
2018 uh a contracted that was so wildly
unpopular drove many members to
unofficially campaign for the O'Brien
Zuckerman ticket speaking out against
General President Jimmy hofa who is a
famed uh son of mobster James haa I want
to note that members had so much control
over this um over their Union that in
2021 General president uh was O'Brien
one O'Brien and Zuckerman W and it was
the first time in the IBT history that a
president was elected that was not
endorsed by the incumbent or was an
incumbent in 2018 I submitted a proposal
for the for um part- timr as a parttime
employee um we were uh mandated to work
a six day given our um production and
that six day was not paid at time and a
half as opposed to our brothers and
sisters that were drivers and the result
of that was an economic victory for my
brothers and sisters who worked on Prime
uh part-time shift as members we are
asked to submit proposals to our Union
for what we want in our new contract um
it is part of the open meetings that we
have and um anyone who is a member uh
May submit a proposal during the recent
contract negotiations am I done already
yes ma'am three minutes goes fast when
you're
focused uh do we have any thank you I
appreciate it well thank you so much do
you have any questions representative
kahill please thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question um I
I'm sorry I didn't catch the name of the
founder of ups but it seems like he did
have an interest in the you know good
well-being of the company and the
employees and I wonder if you could
contrast that because I see a lot of
brown trucks and then I see the same
shape of truck only it's blue and
sometimes it's a van and sometimes it's
a private vehicle with someone wearing
uh an Amazon uh logo shirt Del making
those deliveries would you be able to
compare and contrast the work experience
of a UPS versus an Amazon delivery
person sure sure I can do that I think
that's a good question uh one of the
things that I would say is the Amazon
has 10 50% turnover rate they're also
one of the highest um rates for uh
worker injury so there is no
sustainability as far as employment in
that sort of a environment um and I do
think that one of the things that the
general public may want to be interested
in is that they are not employed by
Amazon they are third-party delivery
services which means that the service
that UPS gives we are a service provider
we are not a shipping company the
service that we provide is um we are
trained we understand safety that is not
something that you're necessarily
getting from the other package uh
services that you um have and um because
we do uh we are mandated to have some
safety protocol in our in our
environment that is something that also
comes along with our union membership if
we are in an environment where it's
unsafe we can go to our um shop steward
we can go to our business agent and we
can say okay these are the things that
are happening specific to like how I had
a a change in our contract that was a
incredible Financial win for part-time
employees so um there is a huge
difference we have a lot more um we have
a lot more control over our environment
as far as our our production our safety
our benefits our um um just it's it's a
completely different environment and our
longevity which is important okay thank
you representa Destro
welcome hi thank you and thank you for
taking my question so comparison on
salary or hourly wage I guess I should
say what's the same is it the same
Amazon to uh yours and then explain the
difference between that that that's a
good question um I specifically am not
uh versed entirely on their different
scopes of employment um I would say that
given our contract a lot of the other
service providers have had to come up
with their pay um our starting wage at
UPS for my specific employment is 21 an
hour um and as a part-time employee I
receive overtime after 5 hours in in my
um in my building um as far as
Amazon I would say they probably are
around the upper 19 or upper um teens um
but when you're factoring an 150%
turnover that wage is completely useless
if you can't rely on long-term
employment with someone and that is
something I definitely guaranteed at UPS
and to speak to that in somebody else's
comment about well I might be a
hardworking employee and the guy next to
me might might not pull his weight well
the fact of the matter is I want
everybody to have a job I want everybody
to provide for their family and I do
work next to people who are may maybe
have some sort of disability and I don't
mind standing shoulder-to-shoulder with
somebody else knowing that sometimes I
have to hold them up and when I'm
well I'm almost 50 when I'm still there
in 9 years somebody is probably going to
have to pull more packages than I do I
go into work and I work uh a shift and I
pull, 1500 packages off the belt and
load them on to package cars which is
three times what some of my co-workers
pull off the belt and I don't care
because they deserve to have a job just
as well as I do okay any further
questions saying none thank you ma'am I
you and Matt glavin
Shapiro good afternoon members of the
New Hampshire house labor industrial and
rehabilitation services committee I am M
Lavin uh local 7 business agent 12E
resident of Derry New Hampshire and vice
president of the New Hampshire Building
Trades I'm a second generation eying
worker who has been in the business for
the past 15 years last May I ran for
election to represent the grant State
and ser not only new union members of
local 7 but even non-union Lo iron
workers across the state I want all
trades people Union or non to achieve
higher wages benefits and safety
standards today I speak in opposition of
HB
238 right to work is bad for the free
market this Law requires a private
business with agreements with another
private business to provide its services
at zero cost the last time I checked
there is no law that requires a private
business to require its services for
free that's bad
business also New Hampshire's legislator
should not meddle in how privac
businesses in the state work together
for their Mutual benefit contracts
between private employers and labor
should be left to the free market
period Right to Work lower safety
standards this legislation is a race to
the bottom on wages across the industry
the construction industry in the whole
country
studies show that wages in right to work
states are almost 16% lower in right to
work states than not safety standards
also diminish in right to work
states workers in right to work states
have a 35 37% chance higher chance of
dying than in states without these laws
we negotiate for these safety standards
and most cases are stronger than the
ocean regulations and we enforce these
to our C cbas we also protect from
retaliatory actions for raising concerns
on safety cons safety issues
also right to work is backed by out of
State corporate interest groups these
laws are backed by interest groups like
Americans for Prosperity there's a
billionaire back shell company that
works tirelessly tirelessly for large
corporations like Amazon and Walmart
they spend Millions trying to make sure
that workers can't collectively bargain
meanwhile that these workers work in
under poor job conditions low wages and
terrible benefits all the while while we
as tax pay payers must make up their
shortcomings social safety nets problem
programs that are constantly being
eroded to cut taxes Walmart employees
make up the largest percentage of those
receiving government benefits race to
Hampshire right to work claims that
protects employees from joining a union
the TA Hardley Act was enacted in 1947
by a federal law which makes it illegal
to be forced to join a union I am
curious where is the testimony from dues
paying members being oppressed by union
dues I have yet to see one today this
law creates Free Riders in our Rank and
file they get all the benefits the
pension the representation the legal
services we provide at zero cost our
members democratically choose the
direction our our Union goes via secret
ballot that goes for wage increases
benefits charitable donations and
Leadership this whole process for
organizing is decided democratically
from our owners and rank and file
employees not
forced and I'll close with a quote from
the great Martin Luther King in our
glorious fight for civil rights we must
guard against being fooled by false
slogans such as Right to Work provides
no rights and no works his purpose is
destroy labor union freedom of
collective bargaining we demand this
fraud be stopped thank you so much
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
if people don't feel that their Union is
bargaining in their best interest why
should they be forced to pay for
something they don't want uh they agreed
to join our Union when uh if when we
organize people they agree to join and
abide by the rcba and the same that
those agreements that take place between
our contractors and our
employees for a followup uh to clarify
the people who are who do not want to
join the Union why should people who do
not feel that the union is bargaining in
their best interest and do not want to
be in the Union why should they pay for
something that they do not
want and just to me it's like I said
it's just Freel loading that's it if
they don't if they if they don't want to
be in the union go find another job okay
representative McKenzie yes Mr chair
chairman uh I'm going to make a
statement and ask you if you if this is
correct so 30% of the employees in a
union can petition to desertify the
Union uh they have that right under the
federal lab relations La is that a
correct statement I'm pretty sure I I I
don't know the specifics thank you okay
any further questions representative
Laing thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question this is very
simple um generally speaking does the
data show that union jobs are on the
rise or on the fall they're on the rise
do you have data to support that I don't
but I just know that the popularity
across this country towards them has has
seen has seen dramatic
increases okay especially the younger
people that are coming up through the
through the through the colle education
through even through trades in general
people like the idea of being able to
stand together Beyond politics follow
okay Jim follow for a followup please um
thank you Mr chair if I wanted to find
this data I was waiting for you to come
up because you have tons of data and I
appreciate that yeah where do I find
this data that tells most stuff the
stuff I did find was from Gallup like it
was polls conducted from Gallop okay
it's important the committee knows
whether or not union jobs are on the
rise or on the fall yeah I mean to you
they're on the rise yeah okay thank you
okay thank you and representative
Schultz I suspect this representative
stab's going to say the same thing we
are in contact with some of the
organizations Gallup that he mentioned
is nonpartisan I'm happy to provide some
research because I love doing that I
think I can find sources that are some
that maybe are skewed to us and I'll
note that and some that are nonpartisan
and do um polling of the whole whole
country uh reported on the news is that
what you say to you no sorry thank you
appreciate that and represent stop U
thank you Mr chair um earlier we heard
from the um uh Carpenters Union that
they have an apprentice program um uh my
question is uh do do the iron workers
also have a similar Apprentice program
and what kinds of jobs do iron workers
do so you know we do heavy construction
from you know things that involve cranes
most of the time when we're doing things
but anything from the concrete that goes
on the bridges the steel that goes onto
Bridges to curtain wall that goes on the
side of the building where you see your
glass to the highrises you see across
you know and then and all the way down
to like stairs handrails you know that's
kind of what our expertise is our
education is the same very similar to
the Carpenters it's at no cost to our
members uh it's provided like we have
funds that um and we also get grants for
some of our programs as well so the
members who do work or decideed to join
a union there is no cost to the
education may ask a followup yes ma'am
thank you
um are there enough iron workers
currently no thank you representative
Granger thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question would you believe
that according to the AFL union
membership has been down consistently
since 1954
I would agree and a lot of it has to do
with laws just like this thank you okay
any further
questions thank you sir I appreciate you
working your testimony than you your
time and uh Lisa
Shapiro Mr
chairman yes sir um while we're waiting
for her to get settled um earlier you
would inform me that there's an intent
to exec this bill today yes sir um and
um
at the time didn't have a big problem
with it but when I'm seeing the amount
of testimony that people are going to be
submitting to the committee and the
amount of written testimony that we've
also received um I'm becoming
increasingly less comfortable with the
idea of executing this bill today for
for us to execute today and then receive
testimony or information that we've
requested tomorrow or the next day uh
seems like an insult to some of the
folks who have uh testified and it puts
us in the position of not not being
fully informed when we do have that exec
vote um so I I I didn't want to spring
it on you at the last second so I'm
springing in on you
now absolutely I understand um let's
hear the testimony and make an
assessment when we get done thank you
that's a good
point over to you Ma'am okay uh thank
you Mr chairman I'm sorry one second uh
John Webb is on Deck okay great thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
my name is Dr Lisa Shapiro I'm an
economist at Gallagher Callahan and
gartell in conquered New Hampshire and
I'm here today on behalf of the AFL CIO
in opposition to HB
238 um Right to Work Advocates assert
that it would um right to work states
outperform non-right to work states you
certainly heard that from a couple of
the speakers today and therefore it
would be beneficial to pass such a law
and that passing it would enhance
economic freedom these arguments should
be rejected on several grounds the best
information published in peer reviewed
journals not just public policy shops or
a statistical analysis but peer reviewed
journals documents that right to work
lowers wages for example a 2020 uh study
in the Journal of financial economics
reviewed nearly 20,000 collective
bargaining agreements
in States over a 25-year period that had
adopted right to work and it found that
in those right to work states there is a
decrease in workers wage growth and an
increase in executive
compensation in a 2023 Federal Reserve
researchers closely analyzed wages in
six states that adopted right to work
and they compare those conditions before
and after and with other states that had
an adopted right to work and in response
they did find and you've heard this
today a slight uptick in employment
that's how I know it's balanced when the
study doesn't just go one way or the
other and this is what you would expect
you may find you know a a handful some
business that comes to the state because
of right to work that's their number one
priority and you may find it and there
is a small uptick in the data however
there was a statistically significant
and quite substantial 4% reduction in
median wages for those people that are
working in those
States so some right to work states are
doing well some uh comp but simply
comparing right to work states with
those that don't you really are missing
what the controlling variables are and
there's competing explanations for high
electric rates we've heard some
discussion business climate so really
studies that claim that this is the
Panacea and these states are better you
really need to look behind and see was
it peer-reviewed is the data there I
know for example there was a paper by a
Harvard PhD business economics students
this has been referred to as the Harvard
study by several speakers today um I
can't find it published in any peer
reviewed uh uh place it has been picked
up by some advocacy places that are in
favor of right to work but I haven't
seen it published anywhere it was cited
and reviewed in the Federal Reserve
paper so people are aware of it but it
didn't find that result thank you thank
you ma'am I appreciate your
suvan thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my uh question um you um
identified yourself as an economist yes
um you come across as an expert um uh
witness um could you give any could you
determine if I'm right about that okay
thank you um my area of specialty as in
economics is really microeconomics not
specifically labor um I have a lot of
background I wrote my doctorate on
property taxes and voting behavior I've
testified on energy policies before the
Public Utility Commission in the state
and in the site evaluation committee on
property tax impacts associated with uh
development projects so I'm not a labor
Economist I have been working with the
AFL CIO uh starting uh this is my third
time on this bill because with my
economics background and microeconomics
they asked me to review the literature
that's out there especially with this
Harvard study and trying to you know
figure out what is the state of the
literature what can we really conclude
and that's what I've provided for today
thank you and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned companies in
other states that have come in again
we've asked this throughout perhaps you
know of some companies that have come
into these right to work states and what
was their Baseline compared to what the
state already had the um because this is
looking at it from a a perspective of
the data they're not looking at
individual companies so translating what
I saw in the data to New Hampshire it
would be something between 100 and 300
new
jobs off of a $750,000 base that's the
some of the literature suggests so you
basically have a um you know a handful
or one big business that might be
attracted now that doesn't mean in every
state that was just in the aggregate
looking at 25 years of History looking
at it you you do find some place
where there is you know a a very you
know it's
0.002% so or something like that um so I
tried to translate that in my in my mind
to what that mean in New Hampshire it
was very small okay thank you for a
followup yes ma'am and just I know the
alarm went off I just wanted to hear
your final thought before you cut off
sure oh thank you for that um I
appreciate that I think the I just
wanted to say about the economic freedom
argument um economic freedom uh in terms
of being right to work is actually
controversial in libertarian thought it
is the majority opinion as far as I
could tell among libertarian thought
with the public policy groups and people
that are advocating but it's it's well
known that some leading Libertarians
like Milton Freedman strongly opposed to
right to work because two wrongs don't
make a right um in fact he's not a big
he was not a big fan of unions but was
definitely against right to work because
felt that that was an interv mention in
the government and business and you've
certainly heard some of that today
similarly KO Institute which does their
uh ranking of 50 states and who's the
most free they admit in their report
that it's controversial among
Libertarians right to work and in the
appendix they uh provide an alternative
Freedom index that does not include the
factor of whether your state has right
to work because they recognize that many
Libertarians and and people that support
freedom in the market Place do not favor
right to
work okay thank you representative
McKenzie uh thank you Mr
chairman it's good to see you again by
the way it's been a while the
um what came up a couple of times during
the testimony was our questions from the
committee were was the whole question of
the Berlin uh what's going on in Berlin
now I don't know if you're in a position
to talk about um why that that why that
part of the state is really struggling
it probably will continue to struggle
for a long period of time I don't know
if you have in looking at data if you
have any opinions about that in
comparison to the southern part of the
state for
instance well I mean um I spent 10 years
working with waaw papers on their energy
policies and trying to get their
electric rates down and I remember the
day we got the call that they were
pulling out completely um which was
extremely disappointing and had a lot
more to do with the broader
industry when you look at the North
Country um and I'm not an expert on you
know their particular issues and studied
it in depth but Top Line it's
older um there's more people over 65
than the state on average there's more
people not in the workforce there's more
people in public sector jobs than in
private sector jobs um and so it it it's
a challenging labor force environment
because it is an aging
population um and I think that makes it
challenging because right now you know
housing has gone up there but it is more
affordable so you than other parts of
the state so why aren't more people
moving to the North Country if housing
is more affordable now there has been
some bump there has been some successes
in the North country and I think that's
great and ex exciting but when you look
at sort of the
fundamentals of high energy costs really
far to tr uh to travel so if you're
producing something and Manufacturing
you got to get on the road and get down
into the bigger markets it's that much
farther to go you've seen some
challenges with um tourism that's really
far north because it's so far away but I
think when you look at the population it
is a challenging population to uh bring
in um a new Workforce but I think you
know there are some bright spots there
and I think we're all hope hopeful and
there has been some turnaround I think
there'll be more but I don't think right
to work um anything that the data
suggests that that's going to um do
anything to change for the positive to
start attracting businesses when the
lead issues are don't have to do with
rights of work they have to do with sort
of some fundamental challenges that
they're that they're working
on okay thank you so
much all right thank you ma'am I
appreciate your time and your
testimony and uhu can we have John web
please
nashii how are you sir good how are you
uh so my name is John the web I prepared
something but it's been reinstated many
many many times uh I'm the training
director of ibw local 490 I run our
apprenticeship um I'm just going to add
the little look a little bit been
nonunion for 10 years I've been Union
for 10 years I join join the union
because of the things that provided me
that I could not get nonunion I could
not get good healthare that didn't cost
me a ton I could not get retirement
those are the things that I came to the
union for and it's benefited me greatly
every year I am seeing over a hundred
people apply to our apprenticeship I
would challenge these non-union
contractors to tell me that they have
that many applicants beating at their
door to get the things that our Union
provides our training is free like the
other apprenticeships you've heard from
and on on top of that we are an
organization we are Community this is
not just union bosses taking money this
is people supporting people this is
people caring about people helping them
get through their rough times there is a
personal connection within this
organization and it is hard to get
outside of that on top of that people
within the unions get paid more and it
covers more than what our union dues
cost so to act like this is some kind of
financial burden on these people is just
a completely misleading thing um to the
people that spoke earlier I just had a
couple comments about that someone said
that 80% of their organization and the
companies within don't want to be Union
they they like right to work then
they're they don't have to worry about
the union they're not going to unionize
if they have 80% people that are in
favor of for right to work um workers
who claim to support the right to work
the actual workers um I believe they're
doing so out of fear for repercussions
for the companies that are giving them
these surveys within their companies and
I believe that they're doing because
they're being misled they're being told
the union will do nothing for them but
take their money which is again just
blatantly false uh and if there are so
many workers that are dying to have
right to work past that they don't have
to pay dues like where are they everyone
here that is pro right to work is being
paid to be here for the most part uh in
the meantime you have dozens and dozens
and dozens and dozens of people here on
their own time taking a day off from
work and sacrificing money to be here to
fight against it in fear that this union
busting bill is going to affect us in
the future that our fund our Union is
going to be defunded through this and
then the people who actually want to be
in a union won't have a union to be a
part of so that's my uh non-prepared
statement that was uh very good thank
you
questions yes
ma'am thank you for taking my question
um are there um are there enough
electricians and the other question is
uh there is electricity everywhere
electric cars renewable energies
everything is being more and more and
more electrified more and more and more
and even the buildings that already
exist need to be retrofitted and
upgraded with LED lighting or the next
type of lighting or the next type of USB
charging or whatever electricity is in
more demand uh AI demands more power for
their servers power distributions a huge
issue we need electricians desperately
and to my knowledge we are losing them
more than we are gaining them because
people have been told that trade work
isn't profitable if you're in a union it
is profitable and not only can you make
good money but you can retire I was
going to work myself into the grave
before I was in the union and I'm now
now I'm going to retire and that is such
relief and those are the kind of things
that we need to extend to the younger
generations to encourage them to go into
these trades which build this country
and are the infrastructure of this
country we will not survive as a country
without Tradesmen doing the work and
they have to be compensated they have to
be treated medically they have to get
retirement and they have to get training
in order to
exist may I some follow up yes ma'am
thank you um my other question is um
once you become a licensed electrician
and go through your training are you
required then to work in a union shop no
we have people that join our Union and
they leave mid apprenticeship for a
variety of reasons we have people that
join our Union and leave after their
apprenticeship and we have people that
join our Union and retire in our Union
they are at free to do whatever they
want there are plenty and plenty of
non-union contractors to work for some
treat you well and give you similar
benefits some do not in my experience
the past 10 years have been the most
beneficial 10 years of my career as an
electrician thank
you sir thank you so much for your
testimony seeing no further
questions thank you appreciate your
Nafi Mr chairman um the rabbi couldn't
still be here um today but she had
written testimony that she
and hopes that the committee will have
an opportunity to read it before the
actual um executive vote on this and uh
just she explains in some detail why the
Jewish tradition the Jewish faith
compels is that in her
testimony great thank you right to work
look forward to reading
that uh
John
Bachelor all right so Eric belcher's on
him that's correct beautiful you're
awesome
so uh I'm sorry sir so John churcher
will not testify he's already left the
thanks and Eric Bachelor yes sir all
Casey oh forgot it's getting a little
older
honorable committee members thank you
for allowing me the opportunity to
testify today I stand before you to OPP
in to oppose the Right to Work
legislation being proposed in New
Hampshire as I believe it will have
negative consequences for workers
businesses and the state's
economy my name is Eric Bachelor and I
live in Farmington New Hampshire and I
started my electrical career in New
Hampshire with one of the largest and
very well-known non-union contractors in
the
state my starting wage was $6 an
hour which was the minimum wage at the
time in
1997 even at that time it wasn't a lot
of money and I needed a second part-time
job which actually paid higher than what
I was getting as an electrical
Apprentice I couldn't afford their
health benefits because it was $6 an
hour I certainly couldn't get into their
retirement their 41 k plan because $6 an
hour I was newly married and I had a
child I needed something better I wasn't
forced to join the union it was my
choice to pay the dues back then and now
I'm still glad to give the small amount
of money that is asked of me for all the
union has given me um and the rest of my
members it has given me Financial
Freedom top shelf Healthcare
in a retirement that is to be
envied it has given me an education
through a registered
apprenticeship and as a licensed
electrician continued education by
offering classes in areas I may have
little experience in or on new emerging
Technologies the best part of this
education it has no out of pocket
expenses to me or to the state or to
Federal
taxpayers that is what a union does it
provides a service it negotiates a
livable wage health benefits and
retirement it provides members with
lifelong education in spite of all of
that our contractors still provide
customers with competitive bids against
open shops who do not provide a portion
of the benefits we receive the community
I live in I pay an HOA fee I pay this
because it was my choice I wanted to
live there I pay dues because this is
where I want to work if I don't want to
pay the HOA fee then I
move if I don't want to pay dues I can
go work somewhere else we do not need
government intervention with these
agreements I'm the business manager of
local 490 located here in conquered New
Hampshire and I represent my members and
contractors in the best capacity I can I
meet with unrepresented workers who are
like me in need of something better and
would like to join to use our
services we look for new contractors
that would like to work with us and we
bridge the gap between the two the best
part of this is like you if my members
do not like the direction I'm going
every three years there is an election
thank you sir for your testimony and I
can be voted
out represent M Granger thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question do you think that people who do
not want to be in a union should lose
their
job if they don't want to be in the
union I don't think they would be at our
doorstep they come to our doorstep
because they want to be part of that
Union thank you sure okay represent kale
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh yesterday we had a
hearing and we learned about uh an area
where the business Community is getting
a really good deal it's uh unemployment
insurance which you know it's it's hard
to compete with that good a deal for
what they get for $84 a year and it
sounds to me am I correct in the
understanding what I've heard from the
other union members that rather the
paying union dues or agency fees you're
getting a lot for your
money absolutely um I mean I'm going
from someone who was the second person
in my family uh to graduate high school
um and that's out of well Christ I've
got 18 uncles and one Aunt so it was a
large family a lot of cousins I'm the
second person to graduate high
school and to be a
homeowner um you know that's that's
that's un achievable
thinking about college gosh that was
like ask me to go to the moon on a
bicycle wasn't going to happen just
didn't have the funds
or or unfortunately the role models
behind us to say you know what I want to
be like my uncle Claude I'm going to be
an accountant I'm going to be a lawyer
I'm going to be what I didn't have those
it was was I going to be a janitor at
you know some or a a store clerk those
were the dreams that I had to look
forward to so getting into this provided
me with all those benefits follow up yes
sir and yet you've done very well you
have a trade a skill that's in in demand
if you come down to my place in New
Market I've got a few things to get you
done uh so good work I thank you for for
your testimony thank you okay I thought
there was a question coming would you
believe I have to work a new market that
I'd like to get done thank you sir all
right any other questions
all right sir thank you for your
you okay Joe Casey Joe Casey here
mcconley uh thank you please thank you
Mr chairman uh members of the committee
my name is Joe Casey uh I am an
international representative for the ibw
I used to have um Eric's job prior to
that I'm from Rochester New Hampshire
uh been in the ivw a long time and I I
in order to not repeat things I I I I
want
to
um the branch of the ibw that I
represent is construction and I also
represent the manufacturing industry uh
in Maine which primarily are the uh uh
four paper mills that I represent up in
in Callis and uh scow heagan Rumford and
um
Westbrook and we work with the employers
but the whole foundation of the ibw had
nothing to do with all these finances
and and who's making more money and
who's this and that it was about
safety construction is a dangerous
dangerous industry and our unions work
with our
employers and we come up with all kinds
of safety safety issues and safety
procedures and protection of our
membership is our number one priority
always has been when I ran the local
union here in New Hampshire that was our
priority and that's where we spent a
great deal of our time on and statistics
prove right so Department of Labor uh
show that um 19% Union construction work
sites are less likely to have an oosha
violation and 34% fewer violations
uh per inspection than on the non-union
work sites now we only represent 14% of
the industry right so
14% of the construction industry
nationally and less here in New
Hampshire I can tell you exactly what it
is
9% um is represented by unions all right
so there's 90 something per 91%
of the shops here in the state of New
Hampshire are non-union Construction
Industries and private private
construction there are a number of
electrical contractors associations that
or businesses that you can go to work
for if you don't want to belong to a
union you want to belong to a union you
want to come into our organization you
want to go to our Union meetings where
you have a voice and everything that
happens from the union bosses which is
me is the is direct Ed by that
membership believe me it's not easy
going to a union meeting and listening
to your members and we had you know 75
80% every month of our membership would
show up and they were active and they
were voice and they and they set their
opinions they tell us what to negotiate
for wages they tell us what to negotiate
they tell us what they're going to pay
us for our salary and our
dues and I'm done I guess sir thank you
for your testimony appreciate it do we
Flanigan yes
sir I do not all
right that was
question all right very good all right
thank you sir I appreciate your
testimony you oh I'm
sorry okay
mcconley all
dibs sorry about that Ste up to use
restroom there no you've been here all
day yeah you know and and there you go
timing is everything and you are I'm
William Lang you're William Lang
patience just save shows
up
good uh my name is William Lang I'm a
resident of Dar New Hampshire I'm also a
representative of the payers and Allied
trades District Council 35 I'm here on
behalf of my membership as well as a
list of contractors that you see on the
second page of the pack that I gave you
um I'm here uh today to to try to
protect Working Families in New
Hampshire by asking to vote no on House
Bill 238 right to
work um we've been hearing a ton of
Statistics today um the thing about
statistics is that depending on what
you're trying to find you can kind of
skew the data usually to to try to you
know make your own argument right um but
I'll I'll I'll jump into that as well a
little bit so on average right to work
states have a poverty level of 11.2%
compared to New Hampshire's
3.7% um I also like to just point out
for a second I can't keep my mouth shut
about this the thought that New
Hampshire has catching up to do to be on
par with West Virginia a state that
Trails the bottom the bottom list of
rankings of every state pretty much for
every metric that determines whether or
not a state is healthy or not um you
know ju just for the record West
Virginia actually has a poverty rate of
16.7% Which is higher than the national
average of 11.2% and much higher than
New Hampshire's average of
3.7% um
so this is due largely to the fact that
all working people in right to work
states Union and non-union earn 12% less
than working people in nonight to work
states working people are also
significantly less safe at work in right
to work states with incidents of
workplace fatalities being
43.8% higher than in non-right to work
states as a working person a husband a
father and a granite stator these are
not conditions that we can accept in New
Hampshire um I'd also like to kind of
talk a little bit uh to the people that
do support this bill um you know I'd
like you to take a look at the people
that are coming in here today the people
that are testifying uh in favor of this
bill but also the people that are
testifying against it um I think that
you'll realize that the people that are
coming in to speak against it with the
people that you want living in your
communities so um working people join a
union because quite often it's the first
real accessible opportunity that we've
ever gotten for Upward Mobility like
every state New Hampshire's facing some
real difficult challenges right now
housing crisis homelessness substance
abuse and right to work is attacking the
very best vehicle that we have to combat
these issues which is unionism Union
membership a Union contract takes a job
and turns it into a career by
guaranteeing working conditions wages
benefits and a dignified retirement pay
attention to how pay attention to how
many people show up to oppose us today
and pay attention to who we are if you
pay attention I think you'll see that we
are New Hampshire's homeowners business
owners taxpayers voters and the proud
working men and women that keep our
communities going in closing working uh
working people benefit from from
belonging to a union and the communities
that we live in benefit from us living
there please vote no on House Bill
238 um and actually on the the third
page that I have for you in that in that
contract there I actually have uh
something from New Hampshire Business
Insider it's an article that they just
did on a signatory contractor Advanced
exterior glazing they were the number
one largest fastest uh growing Private
Industry business against any business
uh industry in the state of New
Hampshire last year thank you appreciate
your testimony thank you very nicely
questions representative McKenzie thank
you um do you have to be a member to
apply for the ibw apprenticeship program
uh I'm sorry I should have actually
specified I'm I'm a I'm a a member of
the panners and Allied trades I'm not
too familiar with that they're not
wearing their colors any other questions
well no I have that's I it's a question
not about what union is from the
question I'm sorry about that brother so
the question is if I okay question is do
you have to be a member of the painters
or the ibw or the iron workers to apply
for membership uh to apply for the job
uh no no you do not so that's a Clos
shop environment uh so employers have
the have the ability to hire off the
street whoever they want um and we as
union members uh I'm sorry as the union
don't actually have the ability to deny
and employer the right to hire
anybody
okay all right thank you so much
NT Robert
n okay long
day
testify my apologies my name is actually
representative hacken Phillips I hope
you have the correct Phillips
representative Mary Hack Phillips yes
you so Mr chair my name is Mary hacken
Phillips of Handover I serve Grafton
District 12 and I'm pleas I'm sorry one
second and this won't count against your
time uh Claudia istel is on Deck
please okay I'm sorry go ahead I'm
pleased to be with you and the members
of the labor committee today I'm here in
opposition to HB 238 because I believe
that right to work is wrong for New
Hampshire my mother was a union member
who belonged to her local union for more
than three and a half decades so I
understand firsthand the Union's role in
building a middle class and a families
like
mine a union fought so that my mother's
work was fairly valued when balanced
with her employer interests and a union
provided strong legal protections for
her and her colleagues at their
workplace a union provided strong legal
protections for them in their workplace
but they also negot negotiated stronger
worker
benefits um upon which she and our whole
family thrived whether it was her
vacation or sick time or health
insurance uh her retirement or her
professional development support or
other employment rights so my life was
built upon this Union and I could not be
more proud of her decision to join that
Union back in the
1970s since we just celebrated the
Martin Luther King Day holiday on Monday
it's worth noting that Dr King reminded
us that right to work laws are
historically rooted in racism and
designed to maintain unequal power in
the workplace Dr King called the right
to work a false
slogan um since right to work laws
provide neither rights nor work uh and
are in fact designed to Rob workers of
their civil rights and job rights and to
destroy labor unions and the freedom of
collective bargaining by which those
unions have improved wages and working
conditions of everyone to be clear the
effect of passage of n of HB 238 in New
Hampshire will be that it will lead to
union busting depreciated workers value
and workplace negotiations and a
degradation of middle class family
strength but right to work harms much
more than the individual worker or the
hardworking middle class family right to
work harms the general public in states
where it's passed as we've heard
today according to in fact according to
the E Economic Policy Institute a
nonprofit nonpartisan
organization and their study data shows
that anti-union right to work laws
damage State economies because these
laws lead to lower unionization rates
wages and benefits when compared to
states without such legislation so
claims that the Right to Work
legislation we're contemplating today
will lead to Greater job growth simply
as misleading and
inaccurate the Epi study shows that
there are no measurable employment
advantages between right to work and
non-right to work states so who benefits
the answer is Mega corporations
corporate shareholders and the rich by
providing greater monetary profits
further exacerbating the wealth Gap here
in New Hampshire so please join the
hardworking Granite State families who
reject HB 238 and I urge you to vote itl
when your committee reaches that
executive session later today if that
does in fact happen thank you for your
time and um given the number of people
who are here to speak I just am going to
decline to take any questions at this
time thank you ma'am appreciate your
testimony and your
West
West sorry thank
you good afternoon uh chairman and
members of the committee I'm Claudia
stelle from aworth I'm a member of the
economic Justice mission team from the
New Hampshire Conference of the United
Church of Christ I have taught for over
30 years in public schools in New
Hampshire and I'm currently an adun at
River Valley Community College I'm also
a union member of Nea New Hampshire and
also SEIU
1984 um and I'm here opposing uh right
to work um for my personal experience I
want to say that I have earned more
money working in public schools than I
have in private schools and part of that
is uh somebody was mentioned that oh I
could have uh negotiated for
my and in a private school I could have
done that but I was a young I was female
there weren't as there were more male
teachers than there were female teachers
and I didn't have I didn't have the shpa
maybe to uh negotiate for myself in that
in that same way um when I moved to
teaching in a public school I was paid
according to my my education my
experience and I knew I could see the uh
pay scale I knew that men and women were
both paid the same I couldn't say that
that was true my previous
employment also I wanted to say that um
later in my career um there was a I was
inappropriately re um lost my job due to
reduction and force that the um School
District had applied in a appropriately
and it was the union that helped me to
get my job back and since my family
relied on my wages and by benefits we
were all very grateful for that
support a couple other things i' just
like to say one is uh we've heard about
the right to work has um comes from a a
racist background I'd like to just say a
little bit more about that the laws
bubbled up in the Jim Crow South in the
194 40s and Beyond and these laws were
all about trying to put a divide between
black workers and white workers when
there was any hint that they might work
together to unionize and one of the key
architects of this law was a wealthy
industrialist and lobbyist from Texas
named Vance Muse and his literature
proposing so-called right to work laws
he wrote and please forgive these
disgraceful words that if right to work
laws were not passed quote white men and
women would be forced to into
organizations meaning unions with black
African Apes whom they will have to call
brother and lose their jobs end of quote
um I've mentioned in my testimony which
I submitted through the portal that not
all those words but that racist
background um the other thing okay ma'am
please your testimony is is time's up uh
are there any questions for this
witness not seeing any thank you mer
very much for your testimony thank you
when I I hope you'll read what I
submitted in the portal I'm glad you
submitted it thank you so much and
ma'am my name is McKenzie West I'm an
appentice with IB Sor on Deck is rousan
Chester go ahead my name is McKenzie
West I'm in appentice with the ibw local
490 here in conquer uh and I'm going to
can my pre-written statement and I just
say
that with the
Union as an openly uh as an open trans
woman in uh the union I find uh a sense
of solidarity and support that often
times my peers and other like other
trans people don't necessarily find when
we Face unequal employment and economic
opportunities uh we and when we also see
discrimination in the all levels of
government targeting our
rights it comes down to the so for me it
comes down to the solidarity I find in
my local union hall knowing that it
doesn't matter where the direction of
politics goes that I have a place and I
have a future in my hall and the right
to work H bills fundamentally
challenge that future and weakening the
uh unions that we belong
to so I am here to vly oppose uh the uh
HP
238 okay thank you so much for your
testimony I appreciate you being here
it and rousan
Clive thank you committee chair thank
you committee members for allowing me to
speak today on this
bill um just to answer some of your
questions or some of the things that
have been brought up since um hearing
some of these things today new Hampshire
is number 21 in growth for um current
unions the top 10 are Hawaii New York
Washington state New Jersey Connecticut
California Alaska Bon Oregon and
Minnesota and the largest growing Union
in the United States today is the SEIU
healthc Care
Union um I was a strong supporter of
unions in the 70s and 80s I marched
along right along with a lot of those um
folks that felt they were being
discriminated in the workplace I have
been both a union member of five
different unions and a non-union member
during my more than 40 Years of
employment that being said I am
supporting this bill today for what it
is it is the choice it is not a Right to
Work bill it is not a Jim Crow law bill
it is a choice uh during my research and
review of the benefits of being a union
member and listening time and time again
to Union lobbyists speaking out against
the very folks that they profess to
represent in these hearings and years
and years and years of hearing similar
to this would you believe that while I
was sitting here today listening to all
this testimony I developed two questions
one how do unions who have come to our
work environments and flex their
financial
muscles um putting out healthy
competition and and the promotion of
growth
capitalism two how are what unions have
become today any different from what Dei
policy and practices have done to our
schools our workplace and our
country it is okay for people to be able
to to be paid appropriately for what
they for what for their job however it
is not okay to give everyone the same
outcome
this is the land of opportunity not
Equity this is the land of you can still
have a dream but you have to work for it
and unfortunately unions have become a
situation today where no one has to work
for it anymore it breaks my heart that
so many of my union brothers and sisters
believe that their employers would still
enslave them and behold them to the kind
of practices that were happening in the
70s
we can do better pass this bill today
and let's prove
it thank you thank you man' I appreciate
questions seeing no questions thank you
I appreciate your
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Drew kleene I am president
of the Josiah baret Center for Public
Policy New Hampshire's free market Think
Tank and we are in support of making New
Hampshire the 27th right to work state
in the United States for a lot of um
prance of economic reasons I know that
you've been here a lot long time so I
try to be short I'm going to summarize a
study that's come up many times in this
testimony which is the 2021 Harvard
University study that I know has been
abanded about but I've got it sort of a
summary and the reason we want to
mention this study is because it's maybe
the most comprehensive study done on
right to work laws because of the depth
of what they tried to measure so I'm
going to go through what some of their
findings and just uh representative
Sullivan I know you asked this question
earlier but to mention the authors of
the study Benjamin Austin is a Harvard
economics professor his previous paper a
large paper he co-authored with Ed
Glazer the chairman of the Harvard
Economic Department and Lawrence Summers
the former treasury secretary under
President Clinton um and former
president of Harvard not a right-wing uh
you know paid troll or anything like
that uh Matthew Lily is also uh Harvard
lecturer with studies labor economics
their study found and I'll just
summarize it really
quickly increase in employment
population so what they did just they
studied border counties in uh states
where one state went right to work and
one state did not go right to
work increase employment to population
ratios which is the percentage of the
working age population who are are
employed by 3 and2 percentage points
increase manufacturing employment by
28% increase total employment by 1.6
percentage points increase labor force
participation rate by 1 14 1.4
percentage
points and then I think we're getting
into some really interesting findings
here which most other studies do not
look
for
reduce the share of individuals below
the federal poverty level by 1.4
percentage points reduced childhood
poverty by 2.3 percentage points that is
a large uh reduction in childhood
poverty they found that the probability
of children born in the poorest 20% of
households the probability that they'll
reach the top 20% increased in right to
work states by 1.7 percentage
points reduced long-term joblessness
reduced Social Security Disability
Benefits recipients by 0.33 percentage
points what does this show what they
talk about in the study is when you pass
a right to work law it tends to attract
and improve the long-term economic
prospects of people who are the hardest
to employ New Hampshire still has not
recovered from prepandemic on our labor
force participation rate right to work
states improve labor force
participation what they did not find is
any reduction in wages or total
compensation and they separated those
out if New Hampshire passed a right to
work law we think that it would
significantly increase manufacturing
employment increase overall employment
and so that's that's time that's time
all right I appreciate it representative
grer thank thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question do you happen
to know off hand if it's if it's buried
in the study somewhere I'm not going to
like require you to like it up but you
say 19% reduction in long-term
unemployment among males do you happen
to know what they consider longterm uh I
can't off top my head answer that butk
there there is a way that they measure
that represent McKenzie thank you uh Mr
chairman uh I haven't had a chance to
read the study sure um but let me say
this I'm somewhat familiar with the
employment trends in New Hampshire and
the
statistics um that are published by the
Department of Employment Security Y and
the question I have in the context of
this uh study has that uh have those
numbers been taken into consideration
can we drill down into that study to get
New Hampshire specific impacts or is
this a more Global study because some of
the numbers that you come up with I
would challenge in terms of the New
Hampshire economy well so these
particular the Harvard study didn't look
at New Hampshire because we haven't
passed a right to work law so this is a
study of states that passed a right to
work law that bordered a state that
didn't pass a right to work law but um
when I mentioned the labor force
participation rate so New Hampshire has
done better than I think every every
state in New England if not every state
in the country on getting back to work
after the pandemic yet our labor force
participation rate is still lower so
we're in the low 60s we were um in the
high 60s before so so we do have a
percentage of the population that still
has not come back to work and that's one
of the things that they found that right
to work can help with
okay and representative laby thank you
Mr chair uh thank you Mr Klein for
taking my question uh to indulge you
what are the other types of businesses
that we could expect that could
potentially come to New Hampshire let
you finish well so it it really depends
and you don't want to make predictions
of the future based on studies of the
past in terms of you know getting down
into the specifics but the Harvard study
is just one of many that found a really
significant increase in manufacturing
employment after States became right to
work state so I think think at the very
least we have
70,000 um roughly manufacturing jobs in
in New Hampshire right now if you look
at the Harvard study which was a 28%
increase in manufacturing jobs there's
another study um that was done a couple
years before um that found a 20%
increase in manufacturing jobs so if you
just take that range um you're talking
14,000 to 20,000 is new manufacturing
jobs in New Hampshire I mean that that's
massive that is a big response and and
there are conflicting findings on wages
right so some studies like the Harvard
one some others have not found that it
reduces wages some have found um changes
in wages but what studies seem to be
pretty consistent on is increases in
employment and increases in economic
growth one of the things the Harvard
research specifically looked at to try
to tease out when looking at those
border counties was the increase in
employment just substituting employment
that already exists in other words were
the new jobs just taking jobs uh
employees from other jobs in the
community and they found that was not
the case that they were net new jobs in
fact they were attracting a lot of
employment from the other state so for
New Hampshire you he a lot of people
complaining about all these people in
New Hampshire we go to work in
Massachusetts becoming right to work
state would to some extent switch that
commuter rate so you would have more
commuters coming into uh New Hampshire
from Massachusetts which helps the local
economy so our review of the literature
on this is that it would be an
unequivocal economic win and when we're
looking at State
revenues
um you're increasing these jobs you're
increasing employment you're adding
businesses you're increasing uh business
activity which increases your business
profits which increases your business
profits taxes we think that if we pass
the right to work law in New Hampshire
Not only would our economy Thrive Not
only would our blue collar worker sector
Thrive but State revenues will go up as
well representative K I'm sorry did you
have a
followup okay got it representative K
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr kle
Sure uh did this study uh control for
items such as demogra de demographics I
know we have we're suffering from a gray
tsunami myself included and and energy
cost uh availability of uh quality
education affordable uh housing anything
like that were those factors considered
well I can't list every single thing
that they controlled for but they did
control for other factors to try to
isolate the effect of right to work law
in particular and that's one of the
things that some previous Studies have
not done very well is try to isolate to
see if the changes were caused by the
right to work law and these Harvard
researchers um concluded that they could
pinpoint it to the right to workw work
law itself um but if you're getting to
the point that I think you asked another
uh
person testifying before about business
relocation look everybody knows that
businesses relocate for all kinds of
reasons right you do look for um good
education you look good Workforce you
look for low taxes you look for um you
know all kinds of costs and inputs right
right to work is a factor and business
um surveys of Executives surveys of
Corporations surveys of leadership but
also studies that track employment all
find that right to work state are
associated with a pretty substantial
increase in employment follow up yes sir
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
uh yesterday during our orientation from
Employment Security we learned clearly
confirmed that we have a we're a net net
negative job loss to Massachusetts and I
I wonder could you tell me if that's for
wages or other employment protections or
I know they're not a right to work state
are they well we're not either um so are
are you asking
so Boston area right is a very large
economy there are a lot of people who
live in New Hampshire who work in
Massachusetts is that what you mean by
net job loss is people commuting to mass
for jobs yes right so one thing you have
to ask yourself is why did those people
move to New Hampshire because a large
percentage of those people moved from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire to then
continue commuting so they came here for
low taxes um often they came for lots of
other reasons but again a right what the
Harvard researchers found was when one
state flips to right to work and the
other state does not you increase
commuting from the non-ri to workstate
into the right to workstate because the
economy and the job growth in the right
to
workstate okay uh represent McKenzie and
I'll come back okay so from a research
perspective yeah
the data that you're
presenting is data that looks at right
to work states and
impacts but there is no specific uh data
correct that would look at New Hampshire
specifically because we could be very
different in a lot of ways from those
States who have adopted it so would it
be legitimate to ask of your group that
they study New Hampshire uh as opposed
to imposing data from other other states
throughout the country um I appreciate
the question uh representative uh that
that's not really how this kind of
research works so to understand what the
impacts are of a change in the law you
look at the states where they actually
change the law and when research have
done that and the best studies on Right
to Work do look at the borders there are
other not just the Harvard study
there've been others that look at border
counties and it's pretty solid evidence
when that happens you get a substantial
increase in employment um manufacturing
jobs overall jobs and these other um
Fallon benefits in the right to work
state and not in the state that didn't
change okay and representative
stop um thank you um I have not had an
opportunity to read the um the study
that uh um you are referring to but I I
did do some other research and would you
believe that in two contiguous states
Arkansas with right to work and Missouri
that has rejected right to work the mean
49,74697 next door in Missouri where
they've rejected right to work um the
$57,900 and then when you look at Mexico
and Arizona Arizona which is a right to
work state has uh $62,000 a year medium
wage and New Mexico is at 53 where they
don't have right to work so it seems
like there are a lot of different um um
things that that contribute to whether
um right to work will improve things or
not and I'm just curious about what you
would uh make of that right so um one of
the problems with the research that gets
out on right to work laws is the
rigor um so you can look at this was a
problem with a lot of the early studies
in right to work states because a lot of
the earlier right to work states were in
the South and so a lot of the non-right
to work states were in the north and so
people were not properly accounting for
cost of living um so you would have
these studies that say oh the the right
to work wages are so low well if you
don't count for right uh for cost of
living you're going to find that it's
apples on Ares so I'm not familiar with
that particular research um but what I
would say is you can look at snapshots
of wages and that doesn't necessarily
tell you a lot you want to try to
pinpoint like the Harvard study and some
other high quality Studies have done um
what the Baseline was and what the
change is once the right to work law
took effect and in those cases they tend
to find a massive increase in economic
activity jobs Etc so we're looking at a
lot of res Arch that shows that right to
work really does improve a state's
overall economy and improve the
employment picture and I think that's
pretty clear from the preponderance of
the research okay representative kale
you pass okay representative
Sullivan thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question sure um You
referred to the rigor of the Harvard
study um we've heard earlier and have
been told that uh it the Harvard study
has not been published it has not been
peer reviewed it's published on their
website sir it's published where um so
I'm sorry I I didn't mean to interrupt
you go ahead I'm I'm talking about
publish in an academic uh manner um and
um so there's there's questions about
the rigor that uh is in place with the
Harvard study can you respond I I I
would respectfully disagree I don't
believe there's any questions about the
rigor
um academic studies are not always
published in in peer rreview journals
that's just the nature of the way it
works um Harvard publishes a lot of its
own studies uh on its you through its
own publishing um one of the authors
works for and is published by the
National Bureau of economic research
which is a highly respected um economic
outfit and those studies aren't peer
reviewed either it's not um necessarily
a ding on the study that it hasn't been
published in a peer-review journal
follow
up on on a different topic um You
referred to the level of employment
participation um being um relatively low
in New Hampshire and um my understanding
is that a large driver of that is uh the
um inaccessibility and the high cost of
child care would Right to Work have any
impact on that
problem that's an interesting question I
don't know that it would have any impact
on child care I mean I think one of the
things you've seen in New Hampshire with
child care is uh regulations uh that
dictate and um Staffing ratios and all
kinds of other regulations on childcare
centers that make it sort of hard to
start one and with child care what you
saw um in the last several years just
like with housing in New Hampshire is a
massive surgeon demand but almost no in
increase in Supply so for childcare you
want to increase the supply I don't know
that right to work is going to
necessarily help with that I don't know
that there are a lot of child care
any further
questions
please so it's your position today that
um that the study that you're talking
about which is controversial in some
some areas that that would absolutely
apply looking at New Hampshire you you
you could analyze the whole environment
within New Hampshire and you can save it
conf now that that would be that that
would be what would happen in New
Hampshire no sir that's not how academic
studies work um you look at what
happened in other states and so one of
the things about the Harvard study and
there are others it's not just the
Harvard one I that's a recent one and it
was extremely thorough which is why it's
cited so much
um you look at the effects when a law
was introduced over the long term that's
what the Harvard study tried to do is
look at the long term and tease out the
effects that they could is ol at and say
and pinpoint with some clarity we're
caused by that change in the right to
work law um that doesn't guarantee that
precisely the same thing will happen but
what they did was they looked at right
to work states around the country so
they could try to get um a ballpark
figure so it's not necessarily that you
would have specifically for example a
28% increase in your manufacturing
Workforce but when you look at the range
that's what they came up with was 28%
across all states that had done this so
it's it's a pretty solid bet when that's
consistent with other studies that show
a a large increase in the manufacturing
work scores you come to the conclusion
that you right to work studies are uh
right to work laws are associated with a
pretty substantial increase in
manufacturing and all sorts of other
things so um that's that's just how it
works you would expect that to happen in
New Hampshire to some degree but you
can't pinpoint the precise number and
say well it'll be 28% thank you that's
important no representative Granger
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
my question do you have a spare New
Hampshire you could pass right to work
on just so we could
compare I wish that would be great you
know and that's one of the reasons we
just to pinpoint this study and the
other studies that look County to County
on those borders um that creates the
control group right so that's why you do
those border studies because you have a
natural control group of the counties on
one side that didn't go right to work
and the counties on the other that did
so that creates that control group so
you can sort of say this was
attributable to the right to work law as
opposed to some other studies that
aren't really quite so good that just
will take snapshots and say well in this
right to work state the wages are X in
this non-ri to work state the wages are
X so therefore you know they're not
isolating that kind of thing it's not
really rigorous thank you very much sure
okay sir thank you so much no other
questions appreciate your
testimony so I just uh I wanted to give
uh Robert
Tom
m Tom mcal and uh representative Coker
an opportunity to speak if they're here
if not then that's okay
too okay great thank you all right uh
are there is there anyone else that
wants to speak on this bill that has not
been afforded the
opportunity sir do if you do come on up
please fill out a pink card I did out P
card okay and your name Tom Rooney then
then that you Tom sorry I I I got you I
worries good afternoon thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak to
you today I come to this discussion
representing myself as a lifelong
citizen of New Hampshire I currently
live in Dober but I've also lived in
Berlin Groveton Manchester Deerfield and
state lifelong citizen of New Hampshire
but I'm also a proud Union member and
vice president of IW local 490 here in
conquer I'll keep my remarks brief I'm
speaking out against this bill it is not
what we stand for here in New
Hampshire it's already been
discussed in this legisl previously
numerous times this legislature voted
this measure
down it's had many names SP sp61 s
sp16 HB
238 this has been voted down there have
been both parties in control of
legislature when that has
occurred this brings us to today's
hearing if this legisl pardon me if this
legislation was voted down
previously it proves that the
legislature no matter what side of the
Alle you we're
on understands the value of unions and
the vital role that unions play in
securing jobs for working
people our elected leaders have
repeatedly defeated this piece of
legislation because they understand that
the free market doesn't need any further
government intrusion or regulatory
burdens into the private business
World New Hampshire's government should
not meddle in how private businesses in
the State work together for their Mutual
benefit contracts between private
employers and labor unions are
businessto business
agreements that this legislature should
leave to the free
market this legislation does nothing for
the working people of New
Hampshire it actually is detrimental it
should be named Right to Work For Less
the average wage in right to work states
is an average of $87,000 less than the
same wage in non-right to work states
like New Hampshire
supporters of this bill claimed that
unions force people to join their
cause using words like coercion and
intimidation in previous versions of
this bill I can personally speak to this
more than seven years ago I
voluntarily again voluntarily walked
into the ibw local 490 Union Hall office
looking for
work I was employed at the time in the
North country of New Hampshire at the
mount Wasington
Hotel I was looking for
change in no way did I feel pressured or
coerced to join this organization in
fact the gentleman I spoke to wanted to
make sure I was serious about
joining as I am in my mid to late 40s
now I have no regrets recently two years
ago I was nominated by one of my union
Brothers to run for vice president I
willfully accepted the nomination and
was elected by the member
and sir your time is up okay um subject
to questions representative Schultz yeah
thank you Mr chair I'm good to see a
neighbor here I'm representative
represent part of conquer so glad you're
here my question is um similar to one
that representative stab has asked a few
times about how many folks are in the
training program at this point and do
how do they make money during that
time um
during I am a product of the
apprenticeship um I was in a five-year
program and I worked while I earned
while I learned I had my classes on
Saturdays
and I worked Monday through Friday and
sometimes there I would not go to class
in order to work overtime when it was
offered but that was very seld them
during th those first five years um
I the the gentleman who spoke previously
John Webb was our Apprentice director he
would have the the the numbers in terms
of our apprenticeship but I know that my
class started with 26 and when graduated
14 so there is there is some Fallout
along the way it's I will say this is
not for everybody what
I've um told apprentices who I've worked
with upand coming in the trade is this
isn't a job it's a it's a career
and to stick with it if you feel because
I have retirement secured for my
family a 10-year-old
who wants me to come and talk to his
class all the
time and maybe he'll be an electrician
maybe he'll go to college I went St
anome College oh sorry I do have one
regret that I did not join the union
when I graduated in
2001 that's my only regret I but I enjoy
enjoy what I do master electrician in
New Hampshire and
Maine um it's provided incredible
opportunities and I have spoken with Mr
Webb about teaching in the
apprenticeship because I do have a
background in
questions thank you thank you for taking
my question you said you worked in a in
an at a at the Mount Washington I used
to I was a front desk agent I worked
overnight shift so I was a zombie all
right so so you left that you walked
into the union hall looking for work
were you once they gave you the uh the
specifics of joining were you infuriated
when they told you you had to pay the
fees NOP I can speak to the dues
actually if you'd like yeah um what I
tell a a lot of people who ask me the
question about the dues my monthly dues
are are equivalent to what I used to pay
for my health insurance and benefits
weekly at Mount Washington hotel is
within $5 of that value and I paay that
once a month I no longer pay out of
pocket for
insurance our contractors cover that
cost as part of the work
package that's the selling point for me
I used I used to pay $40 $50 a
week and that and my wife worked at
Mount Washington as well she had her own
insurance and when our son was born he
was on Medicaid so he had his own
insurance we didn't have a family plan
plan it as as someone spoke to earlier
in the North Country it is a very
depressed
economy and I
drove 45 minutes to an hour to go to
work from greton down to Breton
Woods okay thank you did you have a
followup
represent representative D Sylvester did
you have a followup okay represent
McKenzie thank you uh the purpose of
this question is to flush out the
difference between a clothes shop and a
union
shop um when you applied when you walked
through that door uh uh ibw yes uh did
they say you couldn't come in here and
get a job unless you were a union member
no so that was the closed shop issue
which is illegal so once you were in
there did they demand that you be part
of the
Union no I had the choice whether to
leave during my
apprenticeship but the question is that
this legislation is f if I'm sorry I
don't mean to to to ask questions
without
permission question proceed okay thank
you um thanks for correcting yourself
yeah it's an Italian thing you just keep
talking uh
so uh the the question I have is you
voluntarily continue to pay the union
once you join the union you continue to
pay the dues correct but under the
provision I'm sorry followup okay maybe
if we just take it as questions rather
than statements and then start from
there
proceed
so I I think it'd be too difficult to
flush this out I'm going to I'm going to
pass thank you thank you sir appreciate
else sir thank you I appreciate your
testimony thank and I do have a copy of
it to present great if you can just give
that to the clerk and then we'll get it
out to everyone perfect thank you thank
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members my name is Alan rap I
represent the New Hampshire AFL CIO and
I'm a resident of Manchester New
Hampshire really brief um I'm here in
opposition to HB t238 FN this year's
version of right to work um you've heard
everything that I would have said I did
want to hop on at the end real quickly
just to state that you've heard a lot
about this Harvard study um it's not a
Harvard study a Harvard didn't decide to
do this study and run the numbers on
this it's two people who were Harvard
economists who had uh published the
study through Harvard and when it's
important to note that the fact that
this hasn't been peer-reviewed the
reason things are peer reviewed so peer-
review just as a definition here for you
it involves submitting research to other
experts in the field who critically
evaluate the methodology data analysis
and its conclusions this study did none
of that um so it would essentially be
like if I had gone to Harvard and I was
an economist and I wrote a paper that I
thought was interesting about beliefs
that I had Harvard published it through
their website because I'm Harvard
Economist and didn't have anybody else
to look at it could say outlandish stuff
and have no bearing in reality
whatsoever but um I guess we can call
that a study but I think most of the
things that you're familiar with when
people refer to a study and cite a study
or data analysis stemming from a study
is something that has been peer reviewed
and is in some kind of academic journal
or something like that so
um yes studies do exist that are not
peer reviewed but I think typically what
you are all used to in this forum and
hearing about data and studies is coming
from a peer reviewed Journal something
where other people in the field have
looked at it and decided you know what
this has validity this doesn't have
validity um that's all I have to say and
I thank you very much I appreciate your
questions seeing none thank you sir I
okay last chance Last
that thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee and the public
members that are still patiently here at
the end of a long and passionate hearing
for the record I'm Daniel popovic Miller
representing Windham and the prime
sponsor of the bill hb2 38 is needed to
protect the rights of every worker to
decide for themselves if they want to
join a union or not nobody's trying to
stop any worker from joining a union
they want to join and testimony from the
union members clearly show that there
are very many happy union members and
that unions provide valuable services to
the people who choose to join them
problem is that nobody should should
force a worker to effectively join a
union whose Services they do not want
and that's all that this bill does
nothing less nothing more yes nobody's
legally forced to join the union anymore
but they are forced to pay the union for
services they didn't ask for while Taft
Hardley did close shops in 1947 they
left it to the individual states to pass
the legislation needed to finish the job
without HB 238 there is no practical
difference in New Hampshire between
being a union member or not if a
non-member is forced to pay the union
this bill is needed to preserve the
workers freedom of choice because saying
if you don't like the union you can find
another job is pretty much going back to
close sh policies that are very much
illegal so that's not really an argument
I would
consider if this was an attempt to
weaken unions we would already have seen
public sector unions slowly wither away
since the 2018 janas Supreme Court case
that provided public sector is a
employees the same protections this bill
would provide private sector workers has
anyone seen the American federations of
teachers or firefighters Union or police
unions gets
weaker they are as powerful and active
as ever just as private sector unions
will continue to be after H b238 becomes
LW the National Labor relation Act of
1935 does allow for members only unions
and they exist and thrive in states that
ended Forest unionism unions are only
forced to provide representation to
non-member workers because the union
receives exclusive recognition that
greatly benefits the Union by eliminated
competition from other unions and by
forcing every covered worker to pay them
that rule exists to prevent non-union
members from being treated unfairly
during contract negotiations they no
longer have a right to participate
in the remedy to this concern is not to
make it even worse by forcing workers to
pay the unions it is to fix the federal
laws that created this problem in the
first place or for the unions to choose
to represent their members only people
have testified that this bill is a way
to take away negotiating power actually
this bill will specifically give more
negotiation power to workers union
members testifying today all spoke
glowingly in favor of the Union if you
talk to union members privately plenty
of them will Express dissatisfaction
with their actual ability to have a say
in how the union has run and no voting
for leadership once every 3 years is not
having a lot of
influence unions will have the same
negotiating power as before versus the
employer but they will have to pay more
attention to individual workers to avoid
making them unhappy enough so that they
elect to stop paying union dues I
strongly believe this will make the
unions better they will have to be more
willing to listen to and truly represent
all their members instead of just
listening to the 50% plus one they need
to win an election every 3 years and
staying stay in control people testify
that if this bill passes the only people
retiring with a pot of gold will be the
company owners tell that to the many
Seattle Microsoft stock options
non-union millionaires to the many
Boston biotech employees that went
through a successful IPO to make
millions as a naturalized citizen we
chose to immigrate to the US because
this is the best country in the world
world for people to succeed based on on
their own hard work and Merit and this
bill will move us further ahead thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
testify in favor of this bill I would be
happy to answer any questions thank you
are there any questions representative
grer thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question people have
claimed that right to work is a race to
the bottom do you have anything to say
subject a good part of it was already
covered by previous testimony from Drew
Klein but let's just basically
remind everybody what that argument is
they compare wages in certain states to
wages in other states and they claim
that the causal relationship for the
lower wages is are the right to work
laws the correct way to compare wages is
to adjust for cost of living you have to
get paid more to work in New York City
than you have to be paid to work in cost
County the costs of living are totally
different any study that does not adjust
for that is a study whose methodology is
U let's say poorly designed there is a
huge amount of data showing that states
that enforced unionism see faster job
and wage growth the states that don't go
back to the testimony we heard earlier
from a union member related to job loss
in the Mills they specifically said that
the jobs went from New Hampshire to
states that ended forc
unionism this is a clear argument that
passing this bill will have a positive
impact because we will now be the place
where other states companies want to
move to we would be the only state
attended Forest unionism north of
Virginia greatly expanding our New
Hampshire Advantage more jobs more
competition for hiring New Hampshire
workers that should lead to hire wages
and unions that have to be more
responsive to the people they represent
outcome any other questions
representative stop thank you
um during testimony today we heard that
the inability to collect dues or agency
fees would undermine the training
programs that we need for um U much
needed trades people in the state um
what would you replace that
with I don't think you'd need to replace
it because when this type of legislation
passes there is data showing that unions
change their practices to be more
accommodating to their members to
prevent them essentially stopping you
know to pay for their services so I
believe that since unions will adjust by
becoming better this will greatly
decrease any estimated losses of income
from those fees and therefore I don't
expect a significant impact on the
training programs which by the way
they're a great example of what a good a
well-run union should be doing I really
appreciate hearing all those stories
from people who are whose lives got
changed for better for the union did you
notice that all of them chose to be
union
members this all I'm trying to do I'm
trying to make sure that unions only
beong representative
farington thank you today we heard a lot
about passing this legislation and how
it' be an infringement on two parties in
the private sector what are your
thoughts on that
well one of the advantages of having
this debate happen every year or two is
that U there are not a lot of new
they there is zero impact on the right
of business to negotiate with a union
the bill if anything already reduces
already existing interference I was born
and raised in a communist country I take
freedom very seriously and would never
sponsor this bill if it actually reduced
Freedom if you want to talk about the
right of businesses and unions to
negotiate there is nothing that prevents
them from negotiating with each other
and reaching whatever deal they want if
businesses want to pay unions monthly
fees for every
employee they are more than free to sell
from their own pocket if they feel that
the union is that valuable what this
bill will do is prevent the employer
from reaching a deal with a union that
allows the employer to reach into the
pockets of employees that did not
consent to this bill and take money to
give to the union
the only
interference in private negotiations is
from the 1935 nlra act which remove the
right of non-union members to negotiate
for their own wages and benefits this
bill reduces that interference but
cannot fully eliminated with the
supremacy clause so no this is not an
infringement on any right to contract
that the clerk thank you Mr chair so
representative um if this bill fails how
will it affect you and your future of
your family and your
future my concern is not for me I don't
pass bills for me and my family I
represent my town I represent my state
and I believe that if this bill fails to
pass it will be a negative impact on the
state overall or at least it will be the
lack of a potential positive impact I
think that it's an opportunity to make
our state better and if we fail to pass
it we will continue to exist and do well
but we could do better if we pass it
follow up please please so do you know
how it will negatively affect tens of
thousands of our constituents our union
members in New Hampshire not just in
this room in the house throughout the
throughout the whole state including
myself it could be a big detriment on my
future and the future of all the people
that this will affect would it be
possible to ask for a clarification as
what the detriment is that you are
referring
to specifically I'm just not sure how to
answer without yes please so you keep
saying it's really not a union busting
thing but there really is because and
like anything like any other business um
say say for instance uh we made it
illegal to pay dues to gyms
how long would that gym stay open if
they weren't able to pay the people they
weren't able to pay the bills to keep
the building open uh they weren't be
able to provide vence to their members
and the Machinery went out of date etc
etc etc how long would that business
stay open and that's very very similar
what will happens to union members if no
one's paying dues to keep things
going my pension could run out all these
different things could run out I
understand I'm actually happy that our
disagreement seems to be based on a
misunderstanding of what the bill does
because your example is what would
happen if somebody if we pass the Bill
making it illegal to pay dues to gyms
this is not what this bill does to the
unions it just says that if you don't
want to be a part of it you don't have
to pay them this would be essentially
like saying that you should only pay
bills to the gyms if you actually want
to be a member which I think is the
current status quo in our country I
don't think I would support legislation
requiring me to pay membership to a gym
that won the uh you know election in my
town and now once fees from everybody
who lives in town for the right to go to
a gym I don't want to go to I will admit
that this is not exactly a perfect
comparison because there is a legitimate
argument to be made that those
unwilling people who are represented
there by the union do get some benefits
and I want to acknowledge that it is not
my intent to you know gloss over that
but at the end of the day it comes down
to if this is such a good deal why don't
people want it why do they try to get
away and by the way we are talking about
people who took the whole if you don't
like this job go to a company that's not
unionized only the have to have the
union follow them and unionize that
company too how many times do we want to
run away until we say I have the right
to be left alone if possible now we
cannot fully do that because again the
federal legislation over rules any rules
that we would
create but I think we have an obligation
to make it better to make it Freer to
make it so that everybody's freedom of
choice is protected sorry for a very
long answer I'm an engineer I don't to
go back to Jesus to explain anything no
it's fine then if I may yes sir um you
kind of answered your own question
saying that if you don't want to be be
there don't be there and and I
understand you're you're saying that
well the Union's following that is going
to make unionize your company too well
we heard earlier that only what
9% of the companies or the people
working in New Hampshire are
union so
why why do you think that I me it's it's
probably not true um that the Union's
chasing everybody around sure they're
they're out there trying to use unionize
people and I get that cuz they want to
grow their base right they want to um
but they have every right to do and and
and myself being a former uh Union Union
boss um I used to talk to Carpenters
about um joining the unions and what I
found was when they I'm sorry do this
testimony or is this a question yeah um
is they do have the do they really have
the right to say no and not be part of a
union and not be chased around I I
believe
that's I think that's something we can
reasonably disagree on because obviously
I feel that they have a right to say no
and I would presume based on the
questions that you probably feel
otherwise which again this is why we
have 400 members in the you know
Representatives Hall the one thing I
will point out though is that you
mentioned that we have a rather low
percentage of unionized shops in which
case I would argue that not that many
people will be negativ affected in the
worst case scenarios even though I don't
believe that you are going to see
significant negative impacts because
again people react to legislation when
you pass a law company adjust their
behavior when you pass this law that
will affect the way a union runs the
union knows what it takes to function in
that new environment and they can see
their unions from the other 26 states
that have this law continuing to operate
just look there and all these do and
Gloom scenarios simply are not supported
by the data yes some of the members will
choose to take advantage of the law but
I don't I'm not aware of any case where
that seriously weakened the union or
anything it took some of the members off
who didn't want to be there in the first
place it you you know I I I would be
happy to go you know over more data but
I I just haven't seen that kind of huge
negative impact that everybody worries
about and I would posit to you that most
likely based on the other 26 States who
did this those outcomes are highly
unlikely in New Hampshire I think the
unions will continue to operate they
will have to be nimbler they will have
to work a bit harder to make their
members happy which in my world is a
really good thing are there any
questions rever stop or Schultz excuse
me um I'm honored to be confused with
her she's great thank you Mr chair um
you know we're friends we've worked on
some bills together and we also
sometimes disagree I'm just curious in
the United States have you been a labor
union member in a job that has a labor
union presence because I actually don't
know the answer to that
question you asked about the Union
States the United States oh my God what
did I just say you asked about the
United States no in the United States I
made a conscious effort to avoid any job
that would require me to be a member of
the union for reasons that I already
test about last time when we had this
bill and I don't want to repeat again in
the you know out of respect for the
committee but I don't know does being a
former member of the youth communist
organization count I don't think he does
and for the record by the way while me
and my distinguished colleague have
worked together on some bills we kind of
agreed with each other that we disagree
on most of them okay represent McKenzie
for a question thank you Mr chair uh the
my question is about the construction of
the legislation yes specifically on line
25 I don't know if you have it uh if you
need a minute to bring I can bring it up
second out of all the windows I had in
my browser you'd think I already had one
with
this I'm up and ready go ahead
please so the the question I have is uh
it's under that section 20 on line 25
section
273 the right to refrain no person shall
be required is the condition of
employment become a member or remain a
member of the labor organization isn't
that currently in federal
law isn't that under the National Labor
Relations Board nobody can be compelled
to join a union or to stay in a union
the only thing they can be compelled to
do is if it's negotiated to pay their
fair share so is this uh is this should
this be
amended to reflect the National Labor
Relations law because this is uh trying
this would not Prevail the federal law
would Prevail in this case federal law
may change court cases have intriguing
outcomes you know I don't think that
this needs to be amended of course if
the committee decides that an amendment
is needed I second term so I know full
well that it's not my bill anymore it's
the committee Bill and anything the
committee pleases to do they will do I
will be happy to offer a thought but I'm
anymore I would just one quickly I would
just say that you're describing what is
a closed shop and those are illegal this
language is illegal you can't force
anybody to be in a laay movement to the
condition okay that's for a committee
consideration I I just I'm reading the
language and I don't see that we would
require it if anything this seems to
reaffirm basically tough hardly toughed
I
disagree the text is there forever you
want to see thank you okay any
questions
stop thank you um I I just looked um and
saw that um eight of the 10 states that
have the wor highest poverty rates in
the country are right to work states M
and many of these states have had right
to work for 20 30 50 years how come they
still have such high poverty rates if
right to work is such a great stimulant
to the economy and makes life so much
better for
people how come that Romania which
stopped being communist over 30 years
ago is still far behind the US in terms
of GDP and a bunch of other metrics they
became a democracy it is the same type
of question right
when you start from a bad place and you
work towards improving it doesn't mean
that in 203 years you will have won the
race changes C changing culture changing
economic outcomes like that depends on a
lot of factors right to work is one of
them those states have other factors
that are holding them back that right to
work can only boo those win you know
push those sales so much so this is a
positive but we never stated an I would
never claim that this is a one thing
that will turn us from you know the 50th
state to the first state in the nation
it's just one of the many parts of
economic policy that can be used to
improve the economy but it's by no means
you know the answer to every question so
it's tough when you
start think about generational poverty
right I mean people who are born to poor
poorly educated families I I come from a
country where I go to my Grandma's
Village and I see kids who go work on
the field at 10 11 years old and their
parents hold them from school because
they need somebody to you know deal with
the land what opportunities will those
kids have and as a government you try
really hard to reach out and give people
those opportunities but you should also
remember that it takes generations to
really overcome those
things I'm sorry again long long answer
I don't want to go too far off topic
thank you are there any further
questions represent
K here and thank you
representative uh in those 26 other
states where there is often it still
seems generational poverty uh do the
workers find that they can go into the
uh supervisor or the company president
and and negotiate better terms and have
you have any demonstration of that
happening to raise them to raise their
salaries improve their health care uh
educational opportunities and lift their
families out of poverty yes the evidence
is in the fact that individuals choose
not to be union members and rather
choose to find jobs by themselves every
individual has the ability what's best
for them and when they decide to make
that choice I have to grant them the
benefit of the doubt that they're making
the choices that are right for them I
don't know whether those choices would
always be the choices that I would make
or you would make or anybody here would
make but they are their choices and they
should be allowed to make them and by
the way if they make bad choices there
will be consequences that's how life
works so to me the only evidence I need
is the choice of people not to join
unions that speaks to you know the fact
they feel that is their best choice
follow up yes sir um thank you again uh
have you have you not heard the
testimony today from the union people
who who have said time and time again
that poverty was their future and
finding that good union job changed that
for them them and their families and why
doesn't this happen in the not in your
right to work
states this happens in right to work
states they are much further behind to
start with most of them so there will it
will take them longer to catch up I do
not know of any data that indicates
Right to Work decreases the economic
output or the job growth or the economy
if anything it increases it so I don't
see how you know we could posit that
some how it's a worst thing to have more
jobs and everything like that
now I really listened to everybody's
testimony for as long as it was in the
room I mean there I have to stretch my
legs here and there it's been a long
hearing and look I am immensely grateful
to the people who came to testify about
how this is a great choice for them this
is why this legislation does not impact
their ability to stay union members and
be represented and get all those things
they value and fought so hard for all
this is doing is saying if you really
don't want any of that you don't have to
pay for it
so you know I don't know how much
clearer to make that okay for Jermaine
question yes tiny little tiny yeah I'll
be tiny jog that so again in those
places where even if there is a union
and the other few employees who don't
want the union for whatever reasons can
they go in and and get a different
arrangement from their boss and what do
they do if their boss says no I keep I
want to keep it simple I don't want to
have different plans what what's their
option then I'm not sure I understand
your question I apologize I really don't
in the in the rights of work states yes
where anyone they could be in a union
and yet they were not they're not
participating in the union not paying
agency fees anything like that not
getting any of the benefits which I
think they still get but they're they're
not participating and not they're not in
the union can they walk into the boss
and say uh I work harder I work I'm I
work smarter give me more money and do
they have an option if the boss says no
I I I pay everybody I'm doing it this
way I'm not I'm not negotiating
separately can they be forced to the
bargaining table nobody should be able
to force anybody to the bargaining table
other than obviously the federal
legislation saying that unions and
employers can be forced to bargain for
an individual when you try to bargain
with someone and they don't want to
bargain with you your remedy is to find
somebody who's more amenable to
discussing the contract right which is
where the whole non- interfering with
the right to contract comes into place I
should be able to choose who I have a
business relationship with whether it's
employment or anything else and if two
parties don't see I toi look it takes
two people to have a relationship
whether it's business or other topics
right you shouldn't be able to force
someone to hire you nor should they be
able to force you to work for a deal
that you don't like both parties should
be able to walk
away like calculus is derivatives it
keeps getting smaller and smaller yeah
it's very small this is a micro question
a m okay yeah I I'm I'm waiting daed
breath just to confirm my understanding
so on that scenario that I described are
you saying that it's the same option go
get another job if you don't like it
here that you're that you're objecting
to for the uh
unions the choice is similar the reasons
for it are very different in one place
people are coerced to participate in an
arrangement they don't like and again I
want to remind you that there is a
difference between people looking for a
job at a unionized company knowing it's
unionized and people already working and
having a union come in right so it's
it's not all the same right but there is
a huge difference when we increase
economic freedom when we increase the
people's ability to make choices
that leads to better outcomes
so the choices are always there look one
of the huge differences in negotiating
as a non-union member and one of the
reasons why I would never take a union
job is that I want to be P paid based on
Merit not based on
seniority I want to ask for my own rules
for example if I would be looking for a
full-time job now I'd probably have to
find one that gives me a heck of a lot
of unpaid
based on the Committees I at right those
would not be accommodations that would
fit in a Union contract I think limiting
my ability or the ability of other
workers to ask for those types of
Arrangements regardless of whether
they're successful or not is bad
economic policy and this is why I'm
suggesting this bill I hope that was
close enough to answering your question
I um I hope so yes that's that's quite
clear I I don't have another question
amazing we're all thrilled no anytime
uh any other questions before we're done
with this
wisness okay thank you so much thank you
very much I really appreciate your
opportunity appreciate it uh we have one
wheeler
yeah and we well we never came off it
we're
good yeah three
minutes representative thank you very
much Mr chair
members and friends on the house labor
committee you've heard a lot today I've
been listening since 10: in the morning
and I can't imagine what it's been like
to have to be here on camera since 10 in
the morning so I'll be brief just to say
that unions are an incredibly important
part to the economy and before we had
unions there were workers living in
essentially favas company towns owned by
the company and when we put in place
policy not just right to but other
policies which restrict collective
bargaining Etc that hurts the economy
you know we heard a lot today just now
also about bad economic policy and how
allowing unions to do this is back to me
bad economic policy is hurting the
unions like I know as a person who's
worked non-unionized job as a server as
a bus boy and unionized jobs that the
unionized job gave me a lot more power
to negotiate my own position and it made
me a able to be paid by Merit because
when I'm a sole worker going to my boss
and saying I'd like this I'd like that
the boss is able to say you're an
individual and I don't have to listen
but if I go with my union and I'm
working a factory job and I have all the
boys and girls behind me who are also on
the floor working that job unionized
then we have the power to make decisions
and to change policy collectively and So
Right to Work we've seen in every state
that past has hurt people's ability to
unionize it's opened up the path for
unions to be broken down and destroyed
and I do not want to see that happen
here in New Hampshire I think that we
should be helping and aiding the unions
more than we already are and this
direction workers are better off with
unions than they are without and I think
the fantasy of the individual worker who
could go out there and fight for their
own
Labor uh without the union is is just
that a fantasy workers can get better
working conditions better labor pay the
reason we have weekends the reason we
have all these things that we enjoy and
celebrate is because of the work that
the unions did almost a hundred years
ago and we should continue and celebrate
that work instead of passing legislation
which would aim to to destroy the unions
but thank you very much for your time Mr
chairman and I hope you guys get a
restful rest of your day thanks for your
patience I appreciate you coming in
thanks
representative are there any
questions
okay I tell you what um let's take 15
minutes take a break make a piss stop do
what you got to do and then come be back
here in 15 minutes and we'll uh in that
interim we'll have a discussion about
day
e
all right I just wanted to personally
thank everyone for their patience their
detailed questions and uh their interest
in trying to figure out exact what's
going on with all this it was uh a lot
of effort and I appreciate ever hanging
in there
uh it was suggested to me that uh we
have
received um a lot of information studies
testimony that was not available to us
uh prior to the committee session and we
listened to
56 people today and uh and so rather
than uh exective today I'd rather wait
for a week and give everyone a chance to
digest what was given to them to uh make
sure that we do D due due diligence for
our
constituents and so we will EXA this on
the 28th along with at least three if
not four of the bills that we listened
yet and listened to
yesterday okay and so that'll be going
into the calendar today and uh we'll be
uh we'll be ready to do that so is there
any business for the committee outside
of
that I just want to say we app I
appreciate it uh I asked a lot of
questions today and I appreciate your
patience and and accommodating some of
those and uh I think you did a great job
handling this it's a complicated subject
there's a lot of opinions about the
Direction Where We should go so thank
you I appreciate it thank you
representative solivan I I'll second the
um opinion that it was a well-run
hearing a long hearing and uh your
patience was um appreciate it um I did
um ask our um uh researcher to um uh
print give us a account for the online
um testimony okay um and they're all
here by name and so on but in terms of
numbers we had 82 in support and
1,390 in opposition that actually
changed so I
understand I'm sorry 14
14,6 1400 1400 okay got you still a lot
gotcha a b ton uh represent kill did you
have
something thank you yes ma'am Mr chair I
just wanted to take a moment to
apologize I know my uh feelings uh and
my desire to correct the record on
something I care deeply about uh but I
should have stopped when you asked me to
so for that I apologize accepted thank
you representative flan again thank you
Mr chairman I'd like to thank the
Democrats for feeding us absolutely
thank you so much that was nice you know
sandwich and uh whatever that thing's
called but I mean is is that feeding or
dep on the outcome you know what
Napoleon said right our army runs on his
stomach thank you so much I appreciate
that as well what else and the cake pops
yeah okay good so uh 10 o'clock uh next
Tuesday on the 28th we will exact four
or five bills depending on on how we do
with the uh with the subcommittee and um
thank you so much for your effort and I
appreciate it and we'll see you next
closed there are a few more sandwiches
in the Box in the back I don't want to